the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
scary positions led to ghastly results
at the U.S women's and U.S open
championships in St Louis when the open
strange and there's no good moves Who
you gonna call that was elshon Moore
Giovanni's question after falling
headfirst into linear dominguez's
opening trap forcing resignation in the
busted position Megan Lee is playing
like a woman possessed defeating
front-runner Jennifer Yu to float back
into the co lead underperforming stars
look like ghosts of themselves can they
bring their winning ways back from the
dead day eight of Otherworldly chess
coming up next
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back everybody to date of the
2022 USS championships and U.S women's
chess Championships held at the St Louis
chess club it's been a fantastic seven
rounds and the tournaments are hitting
up who is going to come on top and
manage to take the lead after round
eight let's go to the studio and find
out with Yasser and anastasi
from the home of Chess in the United
States welcome to the Saint Louis chess
club and the eighth round of the U.S
chess championships and U.S women's
chess championships
foreign
and welcome to Saint Louis I'm Anastasia
carlowicz joined by Grandmaster and
four-time U.S Champion Yasser ceremon
now yes sir you cannot send it back to
me
I'm trying I'm thinking honest sassy I'm
gonna get there I'll have something to
say you can be sure hello everyone and
Welcome to our show as we get ready for
round eight of these championships and
they are indeed really heating up in
fact a near explosion of decisive games
and as the smoke is settled tell us
about our tournament leaders let's start
with the ladies Anastasia yeah we have
few ladies on the top I mean Arena Crush
was here but we lost Jennifer York from
the first place so Irina shares the
first place with Megan leave with five
points out of seven then Jennifer is on
the third position right now we have
begging package on our Alice Lee sharing
fourth place and in the open section
what's going on there
[Music]
keeps one point leads very nice yes he's
on the first place and then we have very
Robson with four and a half points he is
a low number second place yes and also
then we have linear Domingos Darius
weird sam7 and a Wonderland uh on they
all died for the third place wonderful
and our formats for these two national
championships so we have four play
around Robin events in each championship
and then 90 minutes for the first 40
moves followed by 30 minutes for the
rest of the game 30 seconds increment
from one and no draw offers we have
passed the halfway mark but what about
our remaining schedule on Sunday we have
still three rounds to go before we have
the second race day which comes on
October 16th then and on other three
rounds and we are here if we need
playoffs October 20th is the date for
the for them and share some details on
the closing ceremonies how can folks
join in the closing ceremony very easy
you can just buy tickets only for 25
dollars and then you will see all your
favorite players as well as your
favorite commentator Yasser cerebellum
and Christian Guerilla and then actually
we have a great schedule cocktail party
first and then the wording ceremony
followed by after party with DJ and in
case if you still cannot do it you can
you are far away then you will have this
option to watch the closing ceremony
online
sounds good I'm not sure about my
dancing with the DJ though I suddenly
put a damper on me uh Christian good to
see you my friend uh tell us about our
tournament leaders great to see you guys
good to be back in the studio calling
the action calling the games of the best
chess players we have here in the United
States and what a fantastic round we had
yesterday nine decisive results combined
from the US Open section as well as the
U.S women's section and let's take a
look at who the leaders are as we enter
the eighth round and we're going to
start with the open section and I want
to highlight this young man because he
is having a breakthrough event he
started off slowly with five draws in
the first five rounds but with the black
pieces fell under a vicious attack by
Hans Neiman defended accurately and
managed to take young Hans down and in
seven in the seventh round yesterday
what a brief really in preparation and a
brilliant play against Wesley so to take
him down and right now he is one point
behind the leader Fabiano caruana and
what a tournament this man has had so
far Grandmaster Fabiano caruana came
into the event as one of the waiting
favorites and right now he is showing
why he is a former 2800 level player he
is on plus 4 and dominating the event so
far he has a one-point lead over Ray
Robson going into the eighth round and
let's take a look at what's happening in
the ladies section of course this young
lady woman International Master Megan
Lee she came to the studio she said she
is having a hard time balancing her a
daytime job with the U.S women's
championships but she is doing a
brilliant job so far she is on a plus
three she had a setback in round four
against Anna satonski but in the last
three rounds well she is definitely
showing her stuff and right now she is
the co-leader entering the eighth round
with one Grandmaster Irina crushed the
a-time national champion and what an
event she's had in the first three
rounds she was a barely not scoring a
point but after that that the damn burst
in round four five and six she scored a
hat-trick and right now she is in the
co-leadership position going into the
eighth round then what a combative two
events we've had so far so many decisive
games take a look at this percentage
59.2 decisive games in the latest
section 38.8 in the open section and the
combined score is 49
decisive results in a classical event we
haven't seen this type of combating
Chess in a while but this is it this is
the US chess championships and we've
been having a lot of fun calling all the
action and look at at this pack of
players looking all relaxed smiling
actually yesterday these two ladies
played against each other it's good to
see that they're back on friendly terms
but uh inquiring minds want to know they
all seem to be drinking a special kind
of tea I think it's just yeah you know
getting that chess player energy going
as we see uh Jennifer getting wanded and
players in a line to pass the security
checks and as we get ready for this
round eight Anastasia lay the table for
our viewers what can they expect in the
ladies pairings let's check the leaders
today
um Arena crush is playing against Sophia
Maurice Suzuki and the white pieces
There's an opportunity there for arena
of course and then Megan leave she plays
against ashrita so also an interesting
fight big Marquee matchup as a Sharif
has also gotten some victories in of
course we have one's really good results
so far and Jennifer you will face
Rochelle and in the open what are the
key pairings uh in the open section
so the leader Fabiano caruano will play
with black pieces against Sam Syrian who
has quite good tournaments exactly
undefeated in one of those players in
that third tied for third trailing pack
Andrea Robson will also have black
pieces but he plays against the poor El
Sean who lost such a crazy game
yesterday yeah will elshon be as
generous and our defending Champion
Wesley so up against darus Lavon versus
Hans again both of those players looking
for a result as we see these two former
world two former world champions two
former U.S Champions Wesley so the
defending champion and there's Fabian
and there's well Wesley so it is a world
champion he's a chess 960 world champion
that is true yes exactly the defending
one going into the November World
Championship that is going to happen I
believe in Reykjavik coming up very very
very shortly actually uh next month
yeah it's nice to see the players
chatting so they want to run and then
Wesley so have a chat and in my view
this is a pivotal round because we have
a big clash between Sam Seville and
Fabiano caruana we remembered what
happened in uh last year's event when
Sam actually took down Fabiano caruana
with the white pieces maybe he will try
to repeat that result and Ray Robson
with the black pieces that's a big
opportunity for him because elshon is
struggling let's be honest up to this
point elshon is struggling only one and
a half points out of seven he definitely
has a Target on his back and Ray Robson
still has one point uh difference
between himself and Fabiano caruana so
he needs to swing some victories
together he needs to catch up and he has
the opportunity to score the Patrick
today we hear the Bell sounding and
we've been seeing great Fighting Chess
Anastasia what are they fighting for in
terms of prizes take us through the list
to the ladies price point yes total
price fund is 160 500 and the champion
U.S wooden Champion will get 40 000 for
the first place
um all these prices go to the 14th Place
which is still three thousand really
good decent price absolutely and in the
open section whether they fighting for
for 262
000 total price fund and the Champions
will get sixty thousand and then the
second place 45 Surplus 35 all the way
to 14th and 5500 and play is underway
also I forgot to mention when you were
making the pairings Christopher you
versus Jeffrey Zhang uh two of the
youngest players in the event uh going
head-to-head as we're looking now at the
game uh Fabi Fabi black against Sam
Sauvignon Sam undefeated having a very
very nice tournament in the chasing pack
uh he's won a game all draws and we see
a nimso uh with Bishop B4 Queen C2 has
become the very very popular
well that's a real indication
yes yes sir yeah that's throwing the
gauntlet in this one right and you can
see Fabiano taken aback by that move
wait a minute wait a minute
yeah what a move I remember I was in
Bonn in 2008 and it was the match
between fishy Anand uh Vichy had been a
E2 E4 player basically his whole life
coming up against kramnik he gets the
nimzo Indian he plays F3
and uh we were all looking at each other
saying is this fishy like like who took
over fishy and uh vichy's preparation
was absolutely absolutely awesome it
looks very strange let's be frank this
move uh you know from our general
principal points of view guys the move
F2 F3 something what is not recommended
by coaches when they start to Flame
cheese exactly you take away the square
for the night but it's not as simple as
that basically white is just saying I
want a huge Center I want to play the
move e to E4 and then I'll occupy the
center after you play the move d75 I
want to play the move A3
so that we get a situation where I have
the double pawns but because you've
already committed your Pawn to D5 I can
liquidate my double pawns whenever I
want with the move C C4 takes D5 uh the
the I want to say the theory has
developed remarkably deeply and the
latest and greatest that I understand
comes from these lines with C5 D5 and
castles we'll keep an eye on this but
let's jump over to you Christian I want
to say I inspired my good body Levon
aronia we discussed about gambits
yesterday in yesterday's interview and I
asked him about the fried liver and
check this out oh really he's playing
tonight and he went for it hi to G5 it
was white pieces yes yes take take
Knight wave five and of course we know
what's happening here white has a lot of
moves actually at his uh disposal Queen
to F2 3 is one of them Bishop to E2 was
the main line for a very long time not
Bishop to C4 of course because that just
gives up the piece but he decided to go
with this move Bishop to D3 it looks a
bit counterintuitive you're putting the
bishop in front of your Pawn but the
idea is behind it is that you're
actually going to develop this bishop
the dark Square Bishop via uh B2 B3
followed by Bishop to B2 and you're
going to couple that with the action of
a potential Rook landing on E1 to put a
lot of pressure on the pawn on E5 and
with the bispawn D3 Knight on G5 as well
you have some ideas and some pressure on
the king side now let's take a look at
what black did Knight to D5 and by the
way they're both playing extremely fast
95 attacking Knight on G5 as well as
getting ready to put the Knight on F4
take advantage of the fact that the
bishop on D3 before I play the move Rook
to E1 is very very important because if
I manage to get the move Rook to E1 on
the board and Knight to F4 comes then I
will just simply drop back my Bishop to
F1 and I will take advantage of the fact
that your 90 is overextended on F4 I
will follow it up let's just say castle
castle was not played we will see Knight
to F4 immediately was played but let's
say you just simply play the move Castle
Rook 31 Knight to F4 and Bishop to F1
and now we understand why the Knight on
F4 is actually overextended and a bit uh
exposed because my next move most likely
once you defend the pawn on E5 as black
with Rook 38 or F6 I'm going to play the
move d4 increase the pressure and take
advantage of the fact that your knight
is on the rim out of play my position is
perfect right now and I'm also Pawn up
so I'm upon up as well as have the
compensation in the position
nevertheless Knight to F4 came on the
board Knight to C3 and we have this
position rising in this game most likely
at some point we're going to see this
exchange Knight takes Z3 C takes D3 and
black obviously is going to have the two
Bishops is going to be working against a
pretty uh bad Pawn structure with the
spawn on D3 and D2 nevertheless upon his
upon so the owners still is on black to
prove full compensation this one is
going to be a very intriguing one oh
thank you for that it's uh indeed the
teen nights variation with Knight G5 a
very rare guest at the highest level
still it kind of brings a smile you know
when you see uh our childhood favorites
let's put it like that yes it's I mean
it's really nice it's a new fashion now
it looks like in this event yes after
this Wonder played this is
it seems to be that it's a new fashion
at least in this event exactly what type
of Chess are we seeing look at what's
happening in your wonder versus Sam
Shanklin game all right take a look at
that maybe we can see it on your boy
what yeah okay so we have a open
Sicilian with an early Queen takes D4
one time this is actually kind of
popular I want to go back later 40 years
but usually after Knight C6
they would go Bishop B5 uh right away
and then against for example Knight F6
they would go Bishop to G5 and white
would seek to kind of leave the queen in
the center the idea is also to make
castling go faster as long as
exactly but Knight F6 E5 yes exactly
that's a very very very rare rare
sighting E5 Knight C6 and now again you
kind of might think that white had
prepared Bishop B5 no no no no
Queen A4 and I have to say this is
really uh news for me uh takes on E5
this thing has been played three times
three times at least according to the
database in the history of Chess this
position has been made three times high
and we're at move six in a sicilian wow
I mean this usually does not happen
three times I will not still be
surprised if Sam knows it
here in this position after Knight C6
Queen A4 two moves I find very
attractive one just to take the pawn the
other is actually I don't really mind
moving uh my knight and these types of
Sicilians while white plays E5 and
especially thanks to the queen being on
A4 I might be happy to kick the queen
again and he captures I probably would
play E6 in order to capture with the
bishop but if you want to play Queen
takes D6 I'm not adverse to this one
either
what on Earth attracted a Wonder to this
line of play Christian another professor
is a very good guess
educated guess most likely he had a
dinner with him
he was like say something weird right
why don't you play E5 with a topical
Sicilian line you might as well and he
found this configuration to actually
work it's a strange position of course I
can go taking on E5 Knight takes E5 and
Bishop to D7 perhaps I can do things of
that nature I can even try to go Knight
to G4 right wow in my position yeah
Knight to G4 put some pressure on E5
take advantage of your overextended Pawn
if you take on D6 I take with the queen
I would assume oh you want to go
well now that you mentioned uh Knight G4
uh as a as a nimso a sicilian player I
couldn't tell you that's nice that's an
awkward one to me he played Knight D5 by
the way did play Knight D5 but the move
Knight G4 actually I like it actually
it's like you try to punish your
opponent for uh his moves with the with
his Queen yeah talk about uh
transgressions being punished what would
have happened after night G4 Christian
Knight to G4 probably the best way and
actually the only way to keep the
balance in the position is to play the
move Bishop B5 okay wow right and they
just like you Queen Basics you have
castling now right right Queen B6
castles but that is well I don't know if
I it's a pawn I can keep it's probably
not because I will take on C6 and I
guess the question is how do we assess
this position you take back on CC
because I have to go Bishop D7 I have
the two Bishops
um you generally like this type of
majority in the center yeah for the
player with the center yeah yeah the
question is is the Pawn on E5 easily
defendable because most likely my
strategy for the next few moves is going
to be to viciously attack that pawn on
E5 and try to put as much pressure as
possible Knight to D2 Knight to C4 maybe
Castle Rook to E1 that's another way F4
the way you're pointing out uh is
another way F6 yes
never never play F6 yes
but no I can imagine that uh I mean
again
if you somehow punish my development but
I don't see it at the moment because
here I have one two three units in play
you have one and after castles uh I
understand maybe one two three let's see
yeah F4 okay we're kind of having fun
with this position absolutely none of
this will actually happen yeah it has
Knight G4 never occurred yes but again
I've got the two Bishops and nonetheless
no I've got Queen B6 check
what just say rookie one let's try to
get some more pressure yeah go ahead and
have your fun okay I'll take it oh
really check show me show me window six
first maybe yes
P3 and you take on B2 you're actually
going to munch on that part so I can go
do you guess
I can go Queen E3
I hear some wait a minute Rook E1 I get
this okay you did I Surrender anything I
did not blunder no no you take only one
king yes and uh no you're okay okay
before was a real challenge I think I
think I wonder well I don't say dodge
the bullet or anything like that but I
somehow I do think that that would have
been a much more challenging uh line of
play than Knight D5 Knight D5 Bishop B5
uh on the board as well and again this
is one of those where you can
force your opponent to capture upon
probably
it's okay we don't have enough
uh but Bishop B5 I guess Bishop D7
if you take again I'm looking but and
actually you don't have time for C4 C5
because Knight B6 again comes with the
thread yeah it's still uh the the only
three maybe yes yeah it's not over yet
it's a a sharp line I suspect it's bad
for white to go into these lines because
it feels like you're really getting
overextended and and bad things could
happen if you're if your pawns all start
crumbling you know it was like basic
anyway something to keep in mind uh
definitely I want to just turn back to
Fabi for a moment before going to the
ladies because I'm curious as to how he
met the move f2f3 yeah
yes F3 at D5 Sam said A3 give me the two
Bishops now for the reasons I mentioned
because I my double pawns I can always
liquidate nope Bishop E2 okay E4 if you
don't follow up with E4 then the move F3
you will really really be bad now here
there's actually a school of thought as
to how you meet this move E4 uh Fabi
went the direct route with C5 another
kind of a funny little way of playing is
to play with the movie E5 a different
approach all all together in terms of
attacking the center what's the idea uh
sometimes you if you can put your Bishop
on this diagonal you make it really
awkward for white to Castle uh
again fabi's super theoretician I'm not
going to teach baby anything he doesn't
know but the lifetime score
between them yeah what is it
look at this so one win for seven three
losses and four doors this only game
during the previous year U.S
Championship yeah right yeah yeah uh C5
uh D5 e takes D5 e takes D5 castles
Bishop E2 and I believe we've caught up
with the players that's a kind of
interesting little move I think a lot of
us would just happily play Knight F3
exactly but uh Bishop G4 Bishop E2
um maybe bishop D6 and Knight D7 well
you know uh who played this one for the
first time at the elite level it was
Fabiano with the white pieces why
against Alexa are the candidates that
was a huge game in fact and I think he
won that handily
um now in that game Alexander responded
with Rook 28 Fabiano decides for this
move A6 and let's take a look after A6
only two games have played so this is
not necessarily a novelty uh but this
position has not been played at the top
level the games are like between players
of 23 62 versus 2368 are rating 22 20 uh
22 41 22 39 rating so it's not at the
elite level I would assume these are
correspondence games but Fabiano decides
to shy away from the main line with Rook
38 which he played against uh as well he
believes that Sam has something there he
smells a rat in the position in his
preparation in Sam's preparation so he
decides to shy away immediately with
this move A6 let's see how Sam responds
in this one wonderful well uh we're
seeing
um
some very unusual approaches to the
openings in this round I'm looking at
the game between the 15 year old
Christopher Hugh and Jeffrey Zhang who's
no longer a junior we can't talk about
The Talented Jeffrey Zhang anymore he's
a Wily old veteran so the Wiley old
veteran has played the Karo Khan
excellent I mean it shows maturity he
shows understanding
Etc it shows that you started yes
exactly F2 F3 the so-called fantasy uh
variation and the idea is it's as simple
as it looks you just reinforce the pawn
on e4 you want to on a good day play
Knight C3 Bishop E3 Queen D2 and our
favorite castles long
now the first time I faced the fantasy
variation I fell into a deep trap
against Dennis fritzinger I thought I
had spotted a pawn E5 very very nice I
have a dual threat Queen Check Yes and
picking up the pawn and picking up the
rook and I was already counting my
chickens Dennis played against me Knight
F3 I captured on D4 thinking I was doing
very very good until he dropped Bishop
C4 on me and I went uh oh like I'm
nearly lost like it's not bad it's like
it's terrible terrible terrible bad
because
castles you can imagine The Rook is
coming to F7 the bishop is coming to F7
the Knight might be jumping to G5 you
don't have Bishop G4 oh so yes I don't
know Bishop F7 maybe bishop F7 and these
types of ideas and uh there goes my
position so later I would uh I I was
clever I crafted this move Bishop E6 the
idea is once again if you take on E5
then I've got this check and I pick my
Pawn back up so this was uh later I
decided that against the fantasy
variation I shouldn't take on e4 at all
I should play the move G6
Knight C3 Bishop G7 Bishop E3 and queen
B6 and I did very very very well on the
black side of this position I'm
intrigued by the fact that Jeffrey
started
V6 and after Knight C3 today E5
wow well again black strategy is as
clear as a bell he's thinking if you
take this Pawn which is probably really
really bad the move Bishop C4 Bishop C5
sorry you're right
Bishop two Bishop takes G so what do you
have to play I mean there is no move
actually yes after that are we up to
date with the players no I'm just let me
refresh my board for just a moment and
see what yeah E5 we're up to date and
Christopher uh sometimes these
um cat and mouse games
sometimes it's not so clear who's the
mouse and who's the cat you know who's
who's tricking whom so Christopher came
with a fantasy variation Queen B6 is a
wrinkle that isn't that well known and
uh this whole setup with E5 surprisingly
enough taking on E5 is not that bad
really yeah okay I would have uh I would
have preferred not to no no it's
probably not the main line but it has
been played quite a few times
um you're not going to see that Bishop
to C5 after taking on E5 is in fact a
blunder not necessarily a big blunder
but you're going to be quite much worse
just under that yeah it's like you just
challenged me to check and it's nothing
right I'm actually giving you away the
Knight on G1 I go Bishop to C4 whoa yes
and you take on G1 I go Queen F3
wow and now you're in fact in trouble no
how is it possible you are you are
because uh well I have to go Bishop E6 I
have to defend against Queen takes F7
absolutely and now I'm going to take
okay
and now I'm going to take advantage of
the fact that you're still one move away
from securing the f file so I'm going to
Target your official first
with a move Knight E2 what exactly it's
it's crazy Knight E2 and I'm in trouble
yes
if you go Bishop C5 yeah and not only
that you're in trouble you're actually
completely lost okay F1 oops and queen
of seven and you cannot protect it
Knight H6 be sure we'll just it's very
strange probably Bishop takes uh H6 but
also maybe uh Queen H5 as well but
Bishop takes H6 probably and if I if I
do something like I don't know Knight D7
and castles long I still I'm just
working then I just take your bishop and
you're worse yeah wow yeah
my goodness what a head scratcher that
turned out to be it is but of course
you're not forced to go Bishop C5 no
after taking on E5 you can actually just
simply develop your pieces and uh try to
take advantage of the fact that that
pawn on E5 most likely is not running
away from you just go Bishop to E6
security A2 uh GA diagonal you don't
have any problems related to the
weakness on F7 anymore and I'm ready to
develop my pieces 97 Castle Bishop to C5
everything kind of comes with Tempo in
the position and that gives black a very
good position and that's why he played
Knight F3 and the current position after
Knight F3 Christian is this all uh thing
it has been seen yes it has been seen in
actually 38 games and quite a few years
a lot I mean compared to seven games
right absolutely quite a few top level
games okay after Knight to F3 Hui fan
versus rubber Rock
um went after he takes D4 Queen takes D4
Knight takes D4 is also an option we're
going to see this type of situation in
which black plays for the weakness on e4
the isolate on e4 and white is playing
for um a development advantage in the
position because I'm ready to go Bishop
to C4 put some pressure on F7 go short
castle if you allow me to if not I will
secure uh this diagonal with Bishop to
E3 Queen to D2 and try to go long castle
at the same time you will have to deal
with ideas of Queen takes B2 so there's
always that poison Pawn on B2 and these
players are going to have uh to uh gauge
let's say the consequences of that move
Bishop to E3 followed by Queen to B2 so
it's an interesting one for sure and
let's wait and see whether Jeffrey still
is within his preparation he plays quite
quickly so he definitely has some ideas
in the position Christopher you has
slowed down after the fight he surprised
his opponent in the opening yeah the
funny thing which I noticed while you
were talking about the moves that
Jeffrey actually put his T-shirt the
wrong way today
probably he was so much in the curry for
the games like if you show it from the
back like I noticed that what he's got
his jacket back on now so you can't see
that the t-shirt is on yeah like if you
see it from the from the tag is the tag
is out
which sometimes happens you know you're
so much focused on your variations on
your opening preparation that you keep
forgetting things I don't know we are
sure if it ever happened to you no my
problem was the socks yeah that's what
that is what about the socks and that
was my problem not the shirts the socks
and I just didn't get the color
coordination was on the socks right
before we uh go over to the women's I
want to take a look at elshon versus uh
Ray Robson my roommate sadly to say that
uh
Alexander shabalov has left today
catching a flight to Ghent and he said
that he had commiserated with elshon and
said okay tomorrow you play Ray Robson
and just play just play the white side
of the Berlin make an easy draw and get
your points uh good advice and guess
what it's a Berlin and will elshon
follow the advice of
um
shabalov just
play solid you know like get your head
back in the game though right yes I mean
after such a game I mean you will see
nightmares for a long time a long time
it's really hard to recover after that
one I really hope he will manage to do
so exactly uh this structure white is
just dreaming give me the move D3 D4 I
will get the the so-called rui Lopez
exchange variation double pawns and I'll
be happy it's not like a Berlin where
the pawn is on E5 upon is actually
better placed on e4 black would like to
play Knight f8 and Knight E6 controlling
D4 probably it's a very good idea to
preface that maneuver with the move c65
just ensuring that D4 doesn't come so
easily for
white let's jump to the ladies and uh
show our leaders uh uh what's going on
as John what is sharifa versus whoa whoa
whoa whoa Megan what is going on okay
and with a2a4 well we saw this yesterday
yes Arena was on the black side and it
nearly won that game and let's see how
it
D2 and Bishop B4 boy am I anxious to
turn this over to Christian Bishop D2
Bishop B4 very uh shall we say direct
approach yes castles
Knight F6 defending the pawn she did not
she said do your worse yes take it oh
and why didn't take it so what happens
if you take it so maybe it's just not
possible
um I'm actually not sure A5 well let's
see if we take with the Knight we've got
an issue right immediately oops what so
if we're going to take it we're going to
take it with the bishop no I would still
continue the land maybe oh so that's it
going before C3 oh that is maybe
absolutely I I stopped the chief but
maybe oh I do it
I do it this way
yeah then black is already for Choice
unfortunately uh in this ending
and for ashrita by the way she she
started terribly she started with like
three losses and a draw from her first
four games so she was at minus three and
much like arena with that hat trick a
victories the shritha is bounced back to
50 so
um castles A5 E4 well it's like the
girls know what they're doing because
this move E4 is yeah I mean it's
basically throwing the gauntlet in
White's direction if you don't capture
the pawn on D6 95 followed by F5 Black's
gonna have a king side attack with no
sacrifice no sacrifices so she did
capture takes takes Knight F6
takes takes and Megan uh
like look I I like winning pawns but uh
one of the crucial things in the opening
is the development
and I mean I'm a pawn Grabber but boy is
she taking a huge risk is Megan this
moments
yes it will be really fine with an extra
bone in the pocket okay but what to do
before okay that's B5 that was that was
my second alternative my first was I was
looking at E3 why am I looking at E3 I I
always like this idea that the knights
being short range pieces need to be in
the action need to be centralized and so
the the if you take uh first of all I'm
not sure about Queen E7 but the move
that I found attractive was this move
Knight E4 jumping into the center
immediately giving ideas of Queen H4
check Queen G5 and so on as well as
rookie eight so E3 you know
the position right I mean like when you
have this King in the center you want to
go and open all files as quickly as
possible so B5 B5 is another one of
those uh so you want to take and take
and that's clear and after a takes B6
Queen takes B6 we can see what's on
ashrita's mind it's as clear as a bell
open up all the files and stuff like
this I think Megan has taken a big risk
uh does Hashi uh Christian it seems like
it but also take a look at the time one
hour and 33 minutes for ashrita so she's
definitely in poor position and she
probably knows what she's doing by the
way this is not the game this is
Christopher Houston watching right now
this is a Chris for you versus Jeffrey
Sean game there we go yes there we go P5
B5 and she played it so fast it seems
like she still knows what she's doing in
the position which is quite uh strange
because there haven't been any games
since before E4 was a novelty by the way
what was it novelty E4
E4 Yes actually there was one game there
was one game in this move uh with this
move E4 but not A6 like Hikaru Nakamura
played uh against nepomayashi not Knight
to F6 to defend uh this Pawn on D6 but
rather the move E4 which by the way it
is the best move according uh to the
engines E4 Bishop takes D6
by the bullet take the pawn and then
defend the pawn but immediately came the
very aggressive B5 and I was looking at
ideas what if I just take on B5 right
right if you take on D5 then maybe I
have time to go Bishop E2 castle and uh
Escape like this but rather
yeah the position for white is after the
movie wow 23 now I'm going to give you
another Pawn right let's say take that
as well are you going to take back no
you're actually going to go Queen to E7
oh my God so now you're down three pawns
only only
three points but I'm actually going to
take all of them I'm going to take D5
after root to d8 I'm going to take E3 if
you don't defend it and if you do defend
it you once again lose a lot of tempies
in the position for example if you try
to go Queen to D2 I take on D5 oops do
you want to take this probably not Queen
takes C32 Rook to d8 Ho Ho your king
easy big big danger right now Rook to C1
is coming uh this is not looking good
for white so she has to be extremely
careful at this point uh she needs to
pull the brakes she needs to find a way
to stabilize the position it seems like
Queen to D4 might be the best way
forward and now I'm not even going to
take because after Bishop takes E4 I
managed to to secure my position Bishop
takes C4 I'm going to go B3 defend the
bishop on C4 and this bishop on C4
despite the fact that after remove B3 it
looks like a pawn but it strengthens the
position quite well for white and I'm
going to be able to stabilize the
position depend upon on D5 and be a pawn
up not only that but I also have the
ultra dangerous majority on the queen
side so this one is good for a white
we're not going to CB takes E4 most
likely right now ashrita is still going
to continue to try to play for
initiative and what's the best way to do
that get your pieces on the dark squares
it seems like you have
um quite an initiative on the dark
squares so Queen to D6 seems to be the
main line in the position take on B5 now
Rook to C2 or Rook to d8 it's wild we're
going to have to wait and see how these
ladies are going to handle the position
but I have to say right now the pressure
is on Megan Lee and she's definitely not
aware of uh the intricacies of this
variation because she's spending a lot
of time right now she only has one hour
and 10 minutes on her clock and
wondering why did I munch on those forms
my opponent is just blitzing out every
single best move in the position and
right now there's so much pressure on
this
also his shirt Christopher
he was a Jefferson
the wrong way yes that's cute
this is what I meant actually because
there was one one moment when we could
see it from uh behind and I noticed that
something is really wrong inside out yes
but I tell you when you're in a rush to
get to the board you know such
considerations
that that actually it's a nice uh
t-shirt
I like it I mean very good
I wanted to ask you B B7 B5 Christian uh
top engine choice or west of course no
no E3 B5 by by far by far yeah yeah yeah
no E3 is already not that good after
Queen to D4 once again it's all about
stabilizing the position uh and
developing my pieces Queen to uh D4 if
you take I actually take back with the
king and you don't have a check on G4
the queen on D4 is perfectly placed you
take control who is the king yes again
I'm only a few moves away I'm going to
go Bishop D3 rookie one and hide my king
I thought I was doing good with uh
compromising the king I understand what
you mean the queen defends everything
you're ready like you say two moves away
from castling by hand Bishop D3 rookie
one and King G1 wow okay but B5
therefore a big time by it is is the
best move by far yeah okay wow wow
actually if you remember she played this
variation against status if I'm not
mistaken it's nicely I wanted to say the
same thing that it was the first time
she ever played this version and now we
see the second game she just got to have
preparation perfectly she came as
shritha did came wonderfully prepared
and she's doing it again she's caught
Megan Lee again Megan with the white
pieces got caught in a variation where
she's saying uh row my opponent's just
blitzing out all the moves and it's not
easy to see a move like Queen D4 trying
to just uh you know harmonize the
position and I love this move Queen D6
by the way because it just Intimates
look I'm I'm wanting to play check and
if I trade Queens capture this Pawn this
one's falling and I have an initiative
so
um big big challenges uh happening right
now for Megan let's go to the game of
Arena Crush our other tournament
co-leader where are you Arena yes there
she is she's up against Sophie today who
is not having a great event Sophie after
winning a game said finally she was
getting depressed it was like all of her
preparation was not appearing on the
board and she wasn't getting the results
either a2a3 F7 F6 so the move a2a3 is
really designed to play the move B4 or
and if you capture everything on B4 I'll
play Knight takes E5 it'll be kind of a
trade of my B two Pawn for the E5 on
Sophie said no no no no no I don't want
to make such a trade let me defend the
pawn and let me see you play for B4
Arena switch gears and said you know
what now that you've played the move F7
F6 weakened the king side I'm ready to
play for d2d4 even if it's a Gambit of a
pawn I figure I'll get away with it
because of the weaknesses on the king
side
E3 Bishop E7 D4 and this is what has
happened we've caught up to the players
I imagine Arena playing the desirable
Knight B5 simply is not playable
94-92 I kind of thinking that she's
going to go for 92. yeah just go for the
pawn right yeah with the idea that maybe
I could
uh Queen B3 maybe B4 B4 B form it's
again yeah
exactly yeah I'm try I'm trading the old
B5 and take on D4 exactly they find
against that with A6 then I just
continue with Bishop B2 once you play D3
I go Knight C1 now yeah it's too
advanced and I'm always attacking that
pawn with every single move I'm
attacking that pawn at some point I'm
going to take it we're going to have
this symmetrical type of structure but
my PCS seem to be better on this I'm
sorry I just have to get it since you're
never taking this one at any at any
moment you know you just imagine this
found getting all the way to D2 and then
to be yeah to be taken
uh intriguing line is this all Theory uh
it is still some sort of theory yes and
by the way 96 Knight E2 was played on
the board I'm 100 sure whether this
theory is good for a black because the
engine is already saying that after B4
actually white is important position to
have a very decent Advantage right close
to a one point Advantage which is quite
significant well let's explain that to
our audience because we're talking about
having our fair share of the center but
we also talk about effective development
it's not that you just go Knight A6 and
Knight H6 and you're opening two moves
and say look I've developed your nights
aren't effective on H6 and A6 out of the
opening now I'm just doing something
just to illustrate the point
whose pieces are more effective this
bishop on G2 speaks for itself gosh I'm
gonna have to stop using this expression
I mean it's terrible you put it out of
yours this bishop is not doing as well
as its counterpart and Rook E1 is coming
so I see this position as being
is significantly Superior as uh I think
White's pieces are much more optimal
than blacks absolutely one example when
pieces are happy
black spaces not so happy sometimes you
can have equal material and you just
hate your position it's just like ah you
know and uh yeah 92 96 before how can
Sophie get out of that well probably she
cannot actually get out of it right well
I mean once again focus on on
development
96 is fine B4 and then just Castle is
there a way for her to toss in a bishop
G4 or a bishop C5 or a D3 Bishop F5 it's
not actually going to help in this
position
um because I'm still going to take on D4
so if you go for example Bishop to G4
yeah
immediately yes I will take on D4
exactly and then again
effective development for white not for
black and you still have to Castle your
B7 Pawn is on pre so you have some
problems in the position so D3 Knight F4
Bishop F5 will probably just get hit by
Knight H4 and again I I don't have the
timing is off and there's a bigger
problem in the position what's that is
that for example after night wage for
Bishop to D7 now you're not Castle so I
have Queen H5 yes
oh that's uh
that hurts that is hurtful uh so uh
Irina looking very good while watching
Megan suffer Jennifer you who Jennifer
is in third position right yes yes Jesus
for those of you who came to the opening
ceremony you'll see that Rochelle and
Jennifer are two peas in a pot boy uh
great friendships tough tough tough
playing your friends but this is the U.S
Championship there are no friends
events and I was thinking maybe why do
you think Yasser actually we have so
many decisive results in this
Championship the other day I was
thinking maybe it's because there are no
drawers maybe that's that that's
definitely a part of it and I also just
think that sometimes you see the
preparation is so good and when somebody
Falls headlong into the preparation I'm
not talking about elshon yesterday
falling into a trap but I'm talking
about tatv falling into shritha's uh
grape rap
um you just can't get out of it it's
like you know you you you you think
you're playing okay but then when you
take a deep breath you realize uh oh yes
I mean there's something here I'm in
trouble yeah I thought also that the
fact that so many young players
participate in this event they kind of
you know show with with their energy we
want to fight we want to play every game
you know we will not just make a draw
even the top players have to find the
way exactly well the you Wesley so our
defending Champion said it uh really
well too that he always loses to one of
the teens and the reason he's losing to
one of the teams is because the teens
are uncompromising they say like I I
want to win and H3 Castle's Bishop F4
it's it's a London system but it's not
with this uh Pawn already on C5 white is
basically saying look I've got a hammer
lock on the queen side you're not going
to uh you're going to be behind in space
for some time you have to play for the
move E7 E5 but I'm not going to make it
easy for you put the bishop on F4 put
the Knight on F3 put the pawn on D4 like
if you go for a move like Knight H5
thinking uh it's going to be an easy
route Road playing for E5 this way well
be careful after a move like G4 not the
only move but you can see it's not going
to be easy for black to get in her
counter play so Jennifer I think is
going to be
happy at the moment with the outcome of
the opening unless Rochelle can get him
B6 and A5 I like the long term plus that
Jennifer has Christian tossing the ball
into your court what do you have for us
I'm looking at this game between tatev
and Talia Cervantes because it's a long
uh battle in a very topical line of the
neither of and we've actually seen
something very similar between Levon
aronium and Maxim vashio legraff at the
sinkfield cup if I'm not mistaken that
went with something like Bishop to E7
King to B1 Queen to C7 Bishop two uh D3
something along this lines it was a very
very complex battle in which white
sacrificed upon on D5 got a lot of
initiative for it and actually won uh
that game handily so very very nice game
by levonne in that one now she decides
Talia that is to immediately put
pressure on the five with the move
Knight to B6 this opens up discussion
how are you going to deal with the move
Queen to A5 which was played in the game
you cannot take on a D5 because of
course after root takes D5 take take
this is obviously a very good position
for white two pieces but not only that
you have full control over the light
squares you have a magnificent position
in this one so Queen 25 was played
Bishop to H6 an indirect way to deal
with this threat of Bishop takes B6 or
queen takes B6 and this is uh
particularly why for example after Queen
C7 King B1 Knight to B6 this is very
very aggressive Queen to A5 and once
again you have to drop back it's not
looking good for black if you do it in
this manner but with the King on C1 you
have this extra option of Bishop to H6
which was played in the game take on H6
Queen to D2 drops back with Tempo Rook
to h8 and F4 F4 E4 and King to B1 this
is the current position we have on the
board and of course the big question is
why won't I take a pause let's take the
pawn right training's working yes
white can indeed get the pawn back so
you can go see for Knight drops back to
E7 and now I have a couple of options I
can take on D6 which I don't actually
think is the best way forward because uh
this particular end game after Knight D7
uh the Knight comes with Tempo on on F5
you only have the E2 Square to develop
your uh bishop and my pieces are indeed
coming quite quickly a black species I'm
talking about after Knight D7 Knight to
F5 so this end game is quite favorable
for a black but what you can do is leave
the pawn on D6 and once again focus on
the initiative in the position play uh
things that maintain the momentum Queen
to C3 attack the Knight on F6 put some
immediate pressure on your opponent
Knight to F5 G3 check this move out I
really like this move yg3 because I want
to go Bishop to H3 Target the 9 on F5
once you castle if I manage to destroy
your Pawn structure on the king side so
let's say castle Bishop Castle why
contact Castle
they should play with is it illegal
she might have wait wait wait wait wait
wait
what is happening here guys what is
happening here G3 is the last move did I
move with the king at any point
yeah
the the the rules of Chess are as
follows if you move the Rook I forget
Castle anymore
but we were discussing about this
situation yesterday yes I believe or was
it two days ago we were trying yes I
think 30 if I was proposing her to make
castle but she had a great opportunity
to make castle but she couldn't because
she was the King right now that he's
moved her Rook hopefully she will not
forget
but yes the position actually after G3
Bishop H3 and those type of ideas with
the king in the center they're favorable
for white
nice I also remember Peter Fiddler
having a problem with the software
wouldn't allow him to play hump Assad
and you know he was just at the moment
he was he was explaining why the
software was so good yes
I wanted to turn to our attention to
energy and Alice for a moment the center
counter a big shout out to uh chess
master Michael Spiegel uh he and I
played a match when I was uh opening
coming up yeah castles castles now the
way Michael played it with white is he
put his Pawn on F3 in these types of
positions uh this is the main move Queen
just three years yeah go ahead okay for
normally the the main line here rookie
four I I used to play it with black wow
yes yes this is the melody if you take
on before then you take Knight takes e4s
written into pieces clever yes a nice
Fork against the bishop as well as the
queen yes well I will defer Anastasia
what happens after Rook takes yeah so
normally it's like Bishop D3 I think
something like that okay oh move your
rock back to Y8 just back down here like
this yes or if three movies even
possible so you lose one or two
templates but you've got a bomb but you
get the pawn in the hand yes yes and
then I mean it's actually quite a sharp
position because why this trend
basically to give you a Checkmate
definitely and it's not that easy to
protect because there are many threads
but okay like black normally holds if
you if you know the theory so it may
move is Rook takes E4 I didn't know that
I mean
but if you don't play if I mean you're
not obliged to know it I mean these are
the lines which you what I mean also you
don't seem to see them so often Central
opening doesn't open every day so yeah
the the center counter I think as
Senator counter is what they called it
a2a3 so from and naji's point of view
she's just playing for fast development
and let's face it she does have her
pieces once you play Rook E1 and or I
don't know H4 H5 uh your all your pieces
are in play and it's going to take Alice
a move or two and Alice is actually
thinking one of the real real problems
when you're playing in such a fierce
competition like the national
championship you lose one game
the previous game yes and people say
You're vulnerable You're vulnerable
Alice lost yesterday and and Nazi is
saying okay and that's how shaken are
you yes she came in in to our studio
didn't actually said at last
uh how shaken are you do you still have
these bad memories of what happened uh
very very recently or are you recovered
yes and we will see how the 12 year old
Alice Lee reacts she's a pawn up but she
can see that her opponent well may not
be threatening Bishop H7 and Knight
Knight G5 immediately but she can see
that her lack of development for the
moment could
potentially have repercussions we'll
keep an eye on that and by the way uh as
always I want to give a big shout out to
our audience thank you so much for
sharing your day with us and we invite
you to join our discussion as Anastasia
any question that you would like
Christian myself will be glad to answer
Anastasia how can they join the
discussion yeah so uh thank you for
many many comments on YouTube channel as
well as little social media this is
definitely happening and actually your
video about Gary Kasparov performing
really well
this story everybody has to watch so yes
exactly
is definitely the place to hang out
these days and you should follow the
Twitter account and then use the hashtag
us chess Champs in order to ask any
question you want exactly and we in fact
have a question let's uh let's have it
let's go from this is from photo
photo
and the question is what are the rules
around the day of what limits are placed
on players from communicating with one
another during these breaks and before
the playoff uh no rules no limitations
if two players want to hang out and just
they share a walk in Forest Park and go
to the zoo or what goes shopping they're
more than welcome to do that I think
that at one time when we had a Germans
there was actually rules that players
who are adjourned couldn't talk with
other players they tried to control
players from helping one another but
during the the the the the the the break
the the time off uh there aren't any
rules and it also that applies to the
playoffs as well I mean if one player
wanted to help another player uh no
there are no I think restrictions no
restrictions is that by the way D7 D6 by
Alice Lee I don't think she took that
long but this is is this still Theory
and guys in fact I think he was also
mentioning the playoffs yes and actually
during the playoffs yeah once you finish
your game you can go outside and a lot
of players do this they go outside the
playing Hall and they speak with their
uh respective seconds and coaches and
things of that nature so uh they do
communicate with people from uh the
outside but not during the games you can
do that once your game is over I
remember that for future random though
there were some restrictions like you
couldn't uh communicate with your
trainers at that time with your seconds
you could that's why I remember we had
groups of players talking to each other
yes just like you couldn't live at this
moment once you know the position you
couldn't leave the plane when you're at
that at that time yes yes so that was
the only time I remember there was this
type of restriction okay interesting I
didn't know that thank you thank you for
the question absolutely uh what do you
have first Christian well let's see what
happened in the tative game because C4
was played and not Knight to E7 and
let's try this castling thing one more
time don't do it I'm gonna do it I'm
just gonna do it on the other side so G3
you have to get the king to safety right
you can either do that by playing King
f8 King G7 but that's a bit too slow and
even once you land on G7 you're still on
this very unpleasant pin so in general
you want to go uh on the long side
Bishop to H3 casts along Bishop takes F5
and this is the big problem right now
Knight to D4 and you have this weakness
on F5 once I capture this weakness and
it's pretty much impossible to defend it
after Queen 2 A5 your opponent D6 is
going to be weak the pawn on H5 is going
to be uh weak we can just look and
compare the structures in the position
and you can clearly see that white is
doing a great at this point so
she decided to go Knight to C7
and now the question is how will Tate
respond to this she has a couple of
options once again taking the pawn
directly doesn't make a lot of sense
because I developed my pieces with Tempo
King to E7 defense the Knight on F6 gets
ready to get uh The Rook on the open a d
file and you're still underdeveloped on
the king side that's why you still need
a couple of moves
and Bishop C4 yes C5 but then I go
Knight to D5 again everything comes with
tempo right for black Rook to d8 is
still going to follow you're still going
to have some problems on the D file and
if you try to go G3 and play like this I
still make moves with Tempo take H4 if
you try to do I I have a feeling I can
even take on G3 give you the piece and
focus on the promotion of uh the pawn
but this one seems to be very favorable
for uh for black now Knight to C7 was
played right now tativ is thinking Queen
to B4 is an option Knight to A5 is an
option but I really like this move F5
take another Pawn why don't you g takes
F5 Knight to D4 once again it's all
about getting the Knight to this
particular Square F5 because on F5 I'm
going to get ready to jump to D6 it's
going to put so much pressure on your
position Queen to D7 for example Queen
to G5 it's all about the initiative play
moves that maintain the momentum in this
type of a Gambit uh position Gambit
situations where you're a pawn down so
this is what that should be looking for
I'm sure she will be spending some time
and trying uh to figure out the best
alternative at this point she has a lot
of options but the problem is when you
lose three games in a row like this is
what happened to touch up in the last
round should she did she lost three
games three games in a row yes and it's
really hard to play and fight for
initiative
yes
I remember there were few a few of them
for sure beg him and
um
I lost two but I might be I might be
yeah people are winning three games in a
row other people
three games in a row but you're right
she started so well with me like which
was on the first title first even but
then I mean something went wrong and
actually when you are in this type of
situation uh you really suffer you like
you kind of you don't believe sometimes
you're right you're confident your
self-confidence exactly unfortunately
but I really hope she will still find
the best moves like you want to
it's really hard it is yes it is because
she's been harboring hopes of winning
this event course so many years every
time she comes to the U.S Women's
Championship she wants to win the event
and she got so close so many times
thought of uh that is so that puts
additional pressure on your shoulders
definitely and we know that she doesn't
play as often she's not such an active
uh player like a lot of these ladies are
so you know there's some Rust in there
and she's showing it in this second half
of this event
all right uh just uh picking up some
games uh I like the fantasy variation of
Kara Khan wanted to see the game between
levonne and Hans and see how that
developed now this was a two nights with
Knight G5 and this bishop D3 as opposed
to the very standard Retreat Bishop E2 a
little bit of a modern twist one of the
points of the position I want to say
major points of the position for White's
perspective is yes it's a pawn but it's
also this offside night if I can take
advantage of the fact that that Knight
is you know out of the way and again
staying within extra Pawn I might be
able to put together a winning Advantage
but we see this move C5 played quickly
by uh Hans as he's preparing his Knight
to return it's a civilization Bishop A3
Bishop A6 Rook E1 give me the pawn yes
rookie 8 let me defend upon Rook E3 all
pieces are on the third rank actually
yeah and funnily enough I according to
the database that I can see in front of
me the move Rook E3 is actually a novel
approach uh previously the obvious
looking Queen C2 had been tried simply
defending the pawn uh the
counter-attacking 94 that will
definitely get my uh seal Mark of
approval uh give me the pawn on I'm
happy to trade the detail upon if you
will and uh remove Rook E3 new move Rook
C8 and I'm expecting Rook C1 unless
am I really going for a tripling queen
that looks strange I'm thinking that um
Black's play is clear you're you're
going to Target this Pawn on D3 I think
my play is clear I want to Target The
Pawn on C5 I'm thinking Rook to C1 and
Knight E4 we'll see how this game uh
develops uh in the game between
Christopher you and Jeffrey Zhang again
the fantasy variation I was more than
curious to see how Jeffrey would play
this he took and played Bishop E6 Bishop
F4 go ahead take my Pawn make my day sis
Christopher green takes B2 Rook B1 my
Rook will land on the seventh right and
then I don't want to see that Knight E7
and that is actually
well let's see what was the new move
here after Queen takes D4
I think Knight F6 and queen takes D4
Bishop E6 Bishop F4 Knight E7 is the new
move nobody has played Knight E7 in this
particular position looks pretty natural
to my eyes want to play the move Knight
G3 and Bishop C5 yes why not Bishop C5
right away because G7 was hanging right
yes that's the problem
well I was really thinking about it
myself especially with Queen takes B2 on
tap right so like maybe it's possible
yes Queen takes G7 you know you can go
check and uh
you just yeah if you don't have Rook d8
though that's the problem yeah maybe
like you can okay yeah Bishop D3 will be
enough even if you want to sacrifice the
stroke and exactly so 97 we've caught up
with the play and finally our tournament
leader Fabiana versus uh Sam uh Sam uh
after the move H7 H6 said you know what
my knight isn't so good on F3 let me
move the knight uh so that I can open
the Rook Knight E1 though I find that
move curious uh
I really want to go after this bishop so
I would almost have preferred to have
seen Knight D2 with the idea Knight E4
okay let's see what happened
not much maybe you wanted to stop I
thought I guess his intention is to go
Knight D3 and Bishop F4 or Bishop F4
immediately
yes sir I really try to understand this
position like which business you have to
exchange which ones you have which are
the good pieces which are bad and it's
not easy at all I mean what you what are
your plans like do you want to push
before a certain point I think you do
black also wants to play B5 I think you
don't yes I know I know but it is tough
right it is it's one of those positions
that it kind of defies you know exactly
what's a good piece what's a bad piece
uh for the moment uh well the bishop C8
black wants to put his Knight on G6 and
block this pawns one day I mean but it
takes time it takes time uh Christian uh
What uh what's caught your eye well just
to speak about this position I think you
guys were definitely on the right track
it's uh the idea of of exchanging the
dark swear Bishops either with Bishop to
F4 first or Knight to D3 He just played
the move Knight to E1 I feel like he's
probably going to go Knight to D3
following that up with the move uh
Bishop to F4 but black seems to be in
time as well for example Rook 28 Bishop
to F4 and now I'm actually not going to
take on F4 but I'm going to propose some
massive liquidations with this move
Knight to E5 can you take the pawn on C5
probably not take take on C5 I have
ideas of Bishop takes H2 but what I can
also do is take take and queen to B6
setup this pin this is not looking good
guys so you cannot do this of course
Queen to D4 by the way okay is hanging
so you cannot do that give me the bishop
okay yes yes
the training has been working
so how is the position after uh these
massive uh trades right the night as you
guys were mentioning probably will land
on D6 you can also keep the Knight on F6
and get this queen on D6 we know the
queen is not a very good blockading
piece but in this particular situation
you cannot actually attack it and that's
why this A6 movie is so important
because Queen to D6 Knight to B5 would
be a problem without the pawn on A6 with
the pawn on A6 you cannot attack that
Queen so Queen D6 Bishop somewhere F5 or
D7 Rook to E8 I'm looking at the
position and I feel like it's easier to
play for black I don't know how you guys
feel about the position I feel like it's
easier to play for a black knight to D3
by the way finally it's on the board
we're expecting Rook to E8 simple moves
uh simple chess is probably the best
type of Chess that you can play right
now with both sides now let's take a
look at what's happening in the Wesley
versus Darius game because this one has
exploded wow check this out into H2 and
are you said you just lost to Ray Robson
you are under a vicious attack have you
recovered yet I might as well try to do
it with the black pieces as well You're
vulnerable right now and you guys were
talking about whenever these players
these sharks smell some blood smell some
weakness in a one player Wesley lost
against Christopher U with the white
pieces lost against Ray Robson yesterday
so right now Darius is like I'm on a
roll I just won two games in a row
against 11 aronian and has anyone I
might as well try to score a hat-trick
right and this is exactly what's
happening right now G5 G3 has been
played in the position and how about G4
actually I used to this is gym position
for black I believe so I played it was
black many times and if you have this
can have this position with all
semi-openf file and move your Knights on
the floor and the six seven life is good
normally you are ready to give give this
Knight even sometimes I think Darius is
very happy right now he probably will
play the move G4 try to break through
maybe G4 maybe even even I don't know
you can wait even maybe with this
movement you can even go night back of
course or maybe not just to play Devil's
Advocate wasn't there a game between
Duda and Fabi in the Bucharest
Grand Chester where black was throwing
everything at White's King and due to
defended it just wasn't that other
candidates was it they can't I think it
was at the candidates right and he
defended just everything perfectly and
and then Black's King just the blacks uh
attack just uh faded yes it was yes so
after the move G4
um
let's just stop for just a second and
what would be the repercussions for
example of night so now let's exchange
on H3 let's take
H3 Knight takes oops excuse me nothing
Knight takes H3 I think
not so easy excuse me for just a moment
I might have a battery problem I'll
double check that on a break it takes
yeah and takes yeah
Queen G6 I'm going to actually play this
one quite slowly Queen E8 Queen G6 H5
Queenie Queen G6 and h57 rook f8 and I'm
asking you what is your plan as white
yeah that is that is exactly the
question I think my knight
actually should be on H4 from yes yes
something maybe if this nature but do
you have time to do it tonight goes
through three we have some checks Knight
to G4 also that's a problem exactly so
if I say go Queen
so this Rook should probably uh get
ready on a good day for F4
yeah and I'm I'm trying you know what
I'm trying I'm dreaming that you will uh
let's say introduce my Rook into the
you'll be very kind and uh with that
King on H3 I don't know yeah I think he
got
h37
who's being served
G4 is on the board guys look at this
here he goes you have to be brave and by
the way I mean you know we talk about
the lack of confidence when you've lost
a game or two but when you've won two in
a row uh your confidence is soaring and
then you start playing you know with
Elan sacrifice here I can sacrifice
there aren't they brilliant aren't they
clever sometimes it works sometimes it's
it's not until as Mike Tyson says you
know you get punched in the mouth but
then you forgot what your plan was
what's our plan where Cube Boutique is
sir yeah tell us about the mates rates
we have very nice items today we have
chess club Polo in the west I mean they
fit together very well and it's a great
combination the Saint Louis chess club
athletic style Polo and West it's
available in a variety of colors and
embossments and women's sizing
it looks nice yeah it looks nice
especially the Autumn is coming the fall
is coming it's good to have something
over over you Paulo absolutely so shop
online right now at Cube Boutique at St
louis.com absolutely and get your Polo
and vest we'll see you on the other side
of the break
thank you
as part of the World Chess Hall of Fame
lecture series author and international
Master John Donaldson will be doing a
live presentation on the 1972 Fisher
spasky match examining their early lives
and careers leading up to their classic
match you can join John live on October
18th at the World Chess Hall of Fame or
watch the live stream on the World Chess
Hall of Fame YouTube channel that's
October 18th John Donaldson live more
information at stlouischessclub.org
foreign
it's the sound of hope
[Music]
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
[Music]
round of personalized Healthcare
[Music]
active communities
it sounds like life and it's what you
hear
when you really listen
listening to you caring for you we are
Ascension
founded in 1839 the University of
Missouri is steeped in Tradition the
recently founded Mizzou chess program is
a partnership between the University of
Missouri and the St Louis chess club
Collegiate Jess has been experiencing a
meteoric rise at the national level
through its tradition of Excellence
Mizzou has always strived for the best
Mizzou chess is working towards raising
the bar by bringing our institutions
ethos of respect responsibility
Discovery and Excellence to the
chessboard
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to round eight of us
championships so let's check the
standings first right yeah no results
and this is how they came into today's
uh round so Irina crushed eight-time U.S
champion and Megan Lee shared the first
place Jennifer you is on the third
position and then we have uh begim and
Alice they share the first place for
Four Points pulling out at first and in
the open section what's our leadership
board look like there Fabiano enjoys his
lead one point ahead of the nearest
rival Ray Robson who has four and a half
points then we have a group of people
tied for the third place linear Darius
Sam I wonder all of them of course are
in chasing group yes at plus one I'm
just looking as we see nice shot of our
playing haul there I'm sure the
tension's been very very high the last
round of plate my goodness what a huge
number of decisive games I can't imagine
that the players will be able to keep up
this pace of decisive games I'm looking
at the game between Alshon and Ray
Robson
um it's funny to my mind blacks achieved
everything he possibly could he's put a
spawn on C5 he's repositioned his Knight
nicely to the E6 Square so it makes it
very awkward if not even impossible to
get in the desirable d3d4 and yet after
the moves Queen D7 and A4 somehow I
can't help myself but I feel like I
actually white like White's position
it's not so easy on the black side
you're going to have to face again ideas
of A5 maybe this Knight will jump to
either to D5 or even to F5 and still the
move d3d4 the point is from Black's
point of view where are his breaks it's
not like you ever really want to play C4
and it's not that easy for you even to
get in the move F5 in other words I
think it's easier to play elshon's
position than raise and we'll keep an
eye on that but of course let's jump
quickly to the game between Sam Savion
and
um our tournament leader where are you
at the very top of course and we did see
the move Knight D3 and Sam is getting
ready to play the move Bishop F4
Christian mentioned the move Rook E8
Bishop F4 Knight E5 and going for those
wholesale trades I I like what Christian
was saying because it's so awkward to
know one of the good pieces and what are
the bad pieces a light Knight takes E5
but I didn't like trading the dark
Square Bishop I was thinking maybe you
go ahead if you want to trade let's do
it on my terms I'm not suggesting that
Bishop takes F4 is the right way for
black to play because because at least
in this case I see my goal I'm going to
play Rook F1 I'm going to play Rook
takes F6 yes
I am and then I'm going to blast on the
king side so uh not there yes problem
with this oh and I'm not sure if it
works or not but can we take on C3 and
go Knight E4 and take again on C3 wow
you have to take with the pawn right
because you have to stick with the ball
yeah because E2 is definitely an issue
right this might not work because you go
there and after Knight C3 you you still
have Bishop to D3 so
you might gone a little bit overboard
here absolutely yeah no so but still I
have Queen F6 we we have to continue
this position Queen F6 protecting them
check on D4 ah Bishop to E3 nice nice ah
and the queen queen is hanging here and
now if I do go Queen to D6 you just take
on C3 and have Bishop H6 wow that's nice
okay this is nice oops that's pretty yes
kind of oops oops uh I do I yeah I'm
sitting there trying to trying to catch
this guy his rather fast footed he's
elusive but you're right I uh in in view
of the move
um what you said Bishop takes C3 I might
just take it back and play something
like Queen C2 Queen C2 is also an option
yeah yeah just so that I can play no and
it's this dance right right trying to
get this trade on your turns and I play
Queen D6 and try to get the trade on my
terms good point yes and that's why you
wanted to play Queen D2 exactly yes
you're you're absolutely right maybe it
means that I have to do it in a
different move order Bishop to D3 get my
Bishop away from the vulnerable uh you
know the Tactical E2 square and then try
to play for Queen D2 despite the
apparent Simplicity of the position it's
actually a very nuanced situation pretty
rich yeah I would uh I would totally
totally agree with that a confounded
game the one between levonne and uh Hans
demon I you know at first blush I
thought
um
uh Lavon was the one with the extra pawn
and was putting pressure on C5 strangely
enough the computer says uh-uh nothing
doing
black is for choice and I was like what
I mean apparently uh the pawn on D3 is
much more vulnerable than I thought and
White's pieces are not making a very
um
attractive Harmony I don't know if I was
maybe one day the move you can play I'm
not sure just kicking this night C5 is a
massively overprotected I'm not saying
that Queen A5 will drive the bishop to a
lesser square but even if you just play
Queen B6 and as you point out F5 uh
black does have a free free hand so that
one is easy to get wrong and Christian
uh over to you what caught your eye this
one between natative and Natalia is
developing quite quickly and let's take
a look at what happened Knight to C7 was
played Queen to B4 we were yes Queen to
C3 was one of them Queen to B4 was
another one A5 was also possible
anything with Tempo seems to be the
right decision at this point Queen to B4
was played Rook to ba defending the pawn
on B7 and now tatv has a very nice
sequence of moves that gives her an
almost decisive Advantage Rook takes D6
the first one is easy right you keep the
attack going Queen to E7 and at this
point you have to ask yourself what is
the biggest problem in White's position
and that seems to be not only the
development but this pin on the A3 f8
diagonal so how do you get rid of that
with Tempo this is key with Tempo Queen
to C5 a big money move in the position
because right now if you play something
like I don't know let's say let's make a
random move Rook to d8 for example boom
Rook takes F6 comes on the board Queen
takes F6 and this is key the queen on C5
is protected by uh the Knight on beat
row Knight on B3 so uh your PIN is
absolute right now on the f8 A3 diagonal
you take I take on C8 and the position
is completely lost I keep trying to go
Castle but it's not working if you're
not castling anytime soon and actually
after Rook to B8 uh you cannot Castle on
the queen side either so Rook takes D6
Queen to C5 if you do go Knight to E6
then I finally find a beautiful Square
for my queen Central Square on E5 and
this one is going to be not all she
wrote yet but it's not looking pretty
for black so if that defines this Rook
to D6 followed by Queen to C5 she has
other moves as well but that is the most
decisive path in the position for tadev
wow uh thank you for that uh Christian
uh
well Rook takes D6 definitely caught my
eye as well I want to turn our attention
to Megan Lee versus ashrita because a
shritha came out in this game guns the
Blazing yes yes she sacrificed upon on
D6 she threw in you know the B5 and the
kitchen table is even the epon so after
B5 what happened uh Megan did not find
the computer recommended move Queen D4
trying to just maintain everything she
played a very human looking move to my
eyes which was this move b2b3 you know
go ahead and take I will recapture with
the bishop very very quickly in order
that I can castle and this bishop may
look bad but no no no it defends some
very good pawns but I think ashrita
played it very well she tossed out E3
okay
Megan did not want to capture that and
fall for the consequences of Queen E7
and or what would happen if she would
take the pawn I think it was Queen E7
that just uh
Crystal's shoulder yeah exactly or even
you know you're just looking at B4 uh 22
94 I mean like really yes it's not easy
uh she did play uh pardon me Megan uh
our tournament co-leader did play the
move F3 Queen D6 Bishop E2 checked King
F1 she's compromiser King she's got the
pawn in the pocket she's trying to play
G3 King G2 but I think ashrita has a
really really uh powerful initiative she
played the move Queen C3 I thought she
was going to play the move rookie eight
and play for an exchange sacrifice based
on like it's very much yeah I mean
combinations are easy when when uh and
you've got such great development Queen
C3
I still like a sharita's position I'm
still not 100 sure I follow where she's
heading with this move but we have a
very special guest from The World Chess
Hall of Fame with Christian thank you
Yasser we are with Chief curator at the
world Chef Chess Hall of Fame Shannon
Bailey Shannon welcome to the show tell
us a bit about your work with the
workshops Hall of Fame sure well thank
you for having me one thing we are
actually in our 11th year and I've been
the chief curator since it it opened so
it's been a really wonderful time to
celebrate you know the last couple of
years of everything that we've done last
year we had a big exhibition
called mine art experience it looked at
all 50 shows 50 that we have done that's
impressive in St Louis and now we've got
this incredible Bobby Fischer Boris
basket show up now tell us about that
because it was just impressive when I
went there and visited thank you um it's
the largest exhibition we've ever done
it's got over 500 artifacts
it is looking because we're celebrating
the 50th anniversary of Bobby winning
the World Chess Championship so it
really looks at not only the match but
the whole origin of Bobby and Boris and
the kind of influence that that match
had so we look at everything from when
they were little kids
we dedicate an entire floor just to the
match and then we look at things like
what happened afterwards it's really
great and you're looking at a replica of
the table there's only two of them those
in existence the the real one is in
Iceland I don't think they'll ever let
that go out but we were lucky enough to
get one it was really fun kind of
recreating that stage and we really
wanted to get a whole feel of like 1972
um it goes you know we're looking at the
games we're looking at all the details
but we're looking at like um how like
the connection that Bobby and Boris had
that they were friends not enemies you
know what did the match mean politically
why was it in Iceland you know it was
really kind of a global event and how
was it received by The Spectators coming
in visiting right um you know you know
we're always excited about the shows
that we do but it means so much to us
especially when the chess players enjoy
the show and I've heard some really
great feedback oh absolutely it's just
amazing and what was your favorite part
putting this together oh my God I loved
this show so much so you know my
background is art history museums and
history and I loved just doing all the
research and research about every detail
I I loved that we had that we took over
the entire museum for the first time
that it wasn't kind of confining us to a
smaller space though we could have done
a show three times the size of what is
over there so you know we'll have a
chance to revisit some of those but I
loved working with you know we worked
with Jonathan Donaldson who's doing a
lecture next Tuesday about some of his
research on Fisher he helped us a lot
with the show just kind of reaching out
to people reaching out to the people in
Iceland that were involved with the
match in 72. there's just a lot of
support for him and people can come and
watch that lecture actually yes and
it'll be streaming you can see it on
YouTube as well but we love John
Donaldson he's so great and he is such a
good friend to all of us and you know he
just knows everything about Chess so we
always go to him if we if we need a
detail and we're so happy to bring him
back and let him talk about some of his
research with Bobby yes sir you know
John quite well he was the best man at
my wedding walking chess encyclopedia I
want to say John is and he did these two
volume books on Bobby Fischer great
great research and assisted you on on
the artifacts I want to say for the the
Fisher match I just wanted to say
Shannon first of all I just love all the
work that you guys in the World Chess
Hall of Fame do all of the inductees a
very very special ceremony just took pay
took place uh heartfelt speeches by
Eugenia Torre and uh Jim Tarzan but for
me hey I gotta ask everybody wants to
know burning boards when do we come back
I mean I loved it the first go-around I
loved everything that happened
to tell everybody what burning boards
was about and how what could we do to
encourage it to come back
um I'm working on it oh yes so burning
boards is a kind of artistic experience
created by the artist Glenn kaino we did
a show a couple years ago curated by
Larry list uh that was about Cajun kaino
so there's some great you know obviously
chess and some music and some sculpture
and um it is you play chess with burning
candles yes and uh it was an elegant
event it was so beautiful I participated
in the one here in St Louis and then a
couple months later I did one at
Brandeis University with college
students it was a completely different
experience but
um you know so incredible both times and
it has always been a favorite and I'm
trying to think because everything's
blending together since I've been here
since day one but it was like eight or
nine years ago I think right and it is
still completely talked about and we
definitely have to do it again yeah just
I just wanted to know that this on the
back burner and and things
all I can say Shannon it it's great to
see what has happened at the World Chess
how Hall of Fame how it's developed and
again just speaking on behalf of my
colleagues the induction ceremonies and
you know the crowning of their careers
it's very special thank you for
everything that you and your staff do
it's great just keep up all the good
work and there's also a music series
happening tonight yeah so we have great
great music events at the hall of fame
we have a great one this evening and
it's looking at some kind of like
highlights of Opera and Broadway we kind
of hit every genre of music and then
after the Fishers basket show closes one
of the new shows we're doing is about
Chess and music and we're also doing one
about trust and literature Emily's
curating that one I'm doing chess and
music with Bradley Bailey and then we're
looking at T.S Eliot and chess so we're
really excited about those shows and
those will open up those will be the
summer shows Shannon thank you very much
for uh what you're doing probably we
will be there tonight yes yes I'm
looking forward your tickets guys yes
for sure to have this unique experience
right absolutely thank you again Shannon
uh very good jumping into the games I
see that Arena Crush by the way is
having a very very enjoyable position
when we left it we saw it at this moment
we were thinking that anything that
allows uh B5 and Knight takes D4 was
terrible so we looked at A6 Bishop B2
castles and we said you know this is
just a very unpleasant position for
Sophie to play she needed to find
something a little bit different than
this she played D3 Knight came to C3
again from Arena's point of view she's
thinking that this Pawn is too far that
it's not going to be possible for black
to save the pawn and whether she she
plays moves like uh Queen B3 and Rook D1
or other ways of winning the pawn uh
once she has accomplished that she will
be much better A5 Bishop E3 ideas of
Bishop B6 even Knight B6 Knight C7 and I
think we're just about caught up take
Stakes B5 95 on the board so if he's
trying to play a very difficult position
Knight takes E5 Queen takes E5 Queen
takes D3 looks really straightforward
because again this bishop on this a long
diagonal yes
yeah you can develop with a game of
tempo but it's just temporary it's a
monster you're absolutely right that
Bishop is going to make Black's life
very very difficult arena being tied for
first in good position Megan has just
played the move G3
I was expecting uh some exchange
sacrifice Queen takes C Queen C3 was the
last move and how is she gonna follow it
up just before we get into how she's
going to follow her up take a look
because ashwitha actually had a win
really before take a look at this
situation
F3 way before yeah Knight takes D5 was
possible in the position just this peace
sacrifice if you take with the queen yes
after Queen to F6 you're busted okay The
Rook on A1 is uh well Rook to C1 I think
exactly Queen D1 queen of two years
the sharks are coming the Eagles yes yes
very nice very nice looks nice so what
if you go Rook to D1 or Rook to B1 right
right let's say Rook to D1 well after
Rook fd8 it doesn't seem like you have a
good place to uh put your queen if you
go here I give you a charge yeah I pick
up the Rook or Brook to D2 and that's a
Checkmate wow so everything once again
oh my goodness this would have been dead
that's a beauty this was deadly could
finish right away right away and the
best movie in the position
if we take with the pawn Chris if you
take with the pawn check and now this is
the key behind this I opened up the
fourth rank yes as well as the C files
that's beautiful queen 24 follows to C3
that's just beautiful it's beautiful it
really is nice
via the second rank so I want to go Rook
to C8 followed by Rook to C2 or Rook
takes B3 followed by road to B2 this one
is pretty much over in the books right
now it's very very difficult to defend
objectively you're completely lost but
if you don't make the most precise moves
you're going to get checkmated in the
next five moves wow this one is not
looking good it wouldn't have looked
good for white she missed it she played
the move point to D6 and in fact right
now what do we think about the position
I mean G3 is coming King 2 G2 is coming
right how do you break through as black
right I'm starting to like white yeah
guys actually this 95 sacrifice it looks
like this one one of one of Michael
Tyler
opponent is really not doing well with
development something like this comes
immediately and and you know there are
certain moves in chess that when when
they're played they have what I can only
describe as shock value like the pawn on
D5 is defended by two exactly including
the pawn you you you you don't even
think about moves like Knight takes D5
the shock value I mean it's just amazing
and queen takes D5 Queen F6 and you see
that with the moves Rook dating
Queen C3 you're winning that's just
that's just great but that is just great
this is important I mean even I keep
telling to my students that there are
certain positions especially especially
when your opponent is uh really really
forgets about development you really
need to find some um some moves which
can some surprise move which will open
the position which you should definitely
be ready to sacrifice material polls
pieces anything so this if you want to
improve you literally need to study some
games of my Mikhail or I mean some
others where you can literally get all
this inspiration how to sacrifice your
pieces and pawns left and right if your
opponent is is behind yeah you're making
a great Point Anastasia you have to be
decisive she did not spend enough time
yeah I think so she actually spent only
three minutes on her move Queen to D6
and she just had to wait sit on her
hands yes calculate Knight takes D5 and
try to figure things out uh for me the
move Queen C3
um I don't know if that was a good move
or a loss of a Tempo exactly in this
position I still like blacks
position I I don't know I was like if I
put the move Rook E8 down I'm trying to
get in the sacrifice of an exchange but
in a nicer way with the Rook on E8 I
think I'm
um supporting this Pawn so that I can
take I can go E2 and take now I don't
think that white is lost or anything
like that I think it white might even be
doing uh well I don't know but I thought
that move Queen C3 was a waste wasted
move is it am I misreading the position
Christian in this game of Megan no no no
normally you want to put more pieces
it's not great right now for ashrita
it's not no no not anymore again it's
just that move G3 followed by King to G2
the king actually is quite safe exactly
you would love once the King goes to G2
to give me some Knight F4 check that's
not possible that pawn on G3 is acting
like a shield in the position absolutely
so G3 King to G2 she found the correct
way to arrange her pieces and right now
that pawn on E3 has uh been an advantage
for your position as black but right now
it's becoming a liability slowly but
surely
way yeah exactly Queen to D3 Rook D1
Rook C1 just developed my pieces and at
some point if we enter the end game The
Pawn on E3 is going to be overextended
also I'm a pawn up also and this is
exactly let's not forget the most
important thing yeah yes exactly I'm
thinking like I start to I start to
think well okay how can I win my Pawn
back Knight to D7 Knight to C5 uh trying
to at least in a case like this okay I'm
a pawn down but pardon me I won't be
gone down I'll get my Pawn back
but definitely Advantage white suddenly
just taking a quick look at Jennifer You
Again Jennifer half a point behind I saw
this position and I nearly got tasered I
thought oh my gosh Jennifer is blundered
a pawn after the move E2 E3 I said well
well let's take it you know just yes
you're like whoops you know this bishop
is x-raying the Knight on C3 you can't
recapture
definitely end of story so Knight takes
C5 but there is Knight takes Knight
takes and queen takes restoring material
quality but now I'm wondering wait a
minute my king is still stuck in the
center what am I going to do after say
Bishop E6 or Bishop F5 just developing
yes I see Rook C8 and I think the worst
of it is behind for Rochelle will keep
an eye on this game and then finally I
wanted to see the center Gambit and what
had happened with Alice and energy well
here we left it to these Port Parts D6
H4 yes kind of an expectation it doesn't
immediately threaten moves like Bishop
takes H7 but it it it it there's
something going on there you know guys I
need to interrupt you please check the
last move of ashirita oh I see Knight to
E4 let's go whoa whoa whoa
Knight takes D5 was more visual a move
or two ago but 94. what is 94. well if I
take what if I take it uh Queen F6 yes
I don't even have to I'm not even about
three I think Queen is King H3 quick
English three yes you don't have a way
to get your Rook on H6 fast and my next
move is The Rook F1 yes
what is what what was 94 again that's a
piece right give me that peace please
yeah well I mean there's no reason to
allow nights at Five maybe I don't know
I'm trying to get the idea FX4 F5 thank
you thank you that might be her
intention but then but that's a
Desperado yes I mean I'm not believing
it's uh uh it's one bit absolutely not
yeah I'm not believing that I hoped you
will but you make a very nice argument
that it's not compelling enough uh yes
you don't trust me at all exactly I'm
trying to open something and exactly
exactly it looks like so if you take on
F1 actually if we go to that variation
sorry I try to uh continue no this was
with F5 you met yes F5 and maybe this is
the point that she missed but even if
she missed that I'm sure there's other
ideas for uh for white to defend you
take I take back with the bishop and
after Rook to f8 I actually have Rook A2
yeah which defends everything maybe this
is the point that she missed sometimes
you miss such moves that
simply can go one but even without that
yeah I have to question whether Rook F2
is a decisive threat yeah can I just
push the pawn yes
exactly that's fine let's say I don't
see Rook to A2 okay right how the size
of a threat is because G1 yes it's
important not to H3 that's fine D7
really you played the seventh maybe I've
got a little bit too but your point is
well taken even here I give you I I go
d8 and go Queen to G4
I mean I am a piece up after all that is
true that is true as long as I don't get
checkmated I'm fine in the position this
Knight to E4 is a very strange decision
I think it it's a little bit shows a
little bit Desperado uh desperation I
meant to say sorry from black I think
she felt that if white gets in King G2
Queen D3 she will lose this Advantage
slips away and this is actually what
happens with the development Advantage
like you want to move so you don't have
it anymore it's gone that's why actually
you have to be really really careful and
take care of your moves because let's
say no mercy you should try to kill your
opponent right in the opening because
it's funny if if there is a way to
punish because in two moves King will go
to G2 finished exactly development yes
wow uh really really good stuff let's
jump back into the open section and just
see a couple of the games going on here
looking at the game of Lavon and Hans
strange strange game I don't I really
don't understand it with these double
pawns Knight to D6 the moment I see that
move Knight to D6 I'm kind of relieved
in truth because I see Knight takes C5
Knight here and I hate my double pawns
you want to get rid of that I want to
get rid of them and the best way is you
know I'll give up an exchange but I
undouble my pawns I get two pawns for an
exchange I'm not saying I'm winning or
anything like that at least I just know
what I'm doing yes
um
it's like so unbalanced with those
phones right whereas uh
and Lavon says I love my pawns just just
fine thank you very much Lavon says I'm
not interested in sacrificing an
exchange Knight takes D6 on the board
the hovering
Queen recaptured on D6
okay
um
that trade of knights might have been
helpful for Lavon I can imagine this
queen finally getting into the game Visa
G4 or even H5
seems probably content
with his tea Yes Yes
actually this tea is really great I must
admit that what is it yes what is this
yes there are different types and I
think everybody enjoys it and certain
remarks from players is it the Moroccan
mint I like that stuff man
you know that honey from the sky stuff
the way they serve it in Tunis is
wonderful social media we have a
question let's see uh if we can get
stumped by our audience
from Michael soon 28.
when this MasterCard was making a run
for the world championship and will she
be using the king's government inquiring
minds want to know yes yes
I can get some funny stories about it
yes we were playing this um hand and
brain games in rigor remember when
everybody was stuck in the hotel and we
were playing with the jababa badur was
there many many many players and we
played many games and at one point Jabba
said I don't understand one thing why
you keep asking questions you have to
play in the championship yourself you
know we will prepare you and things like
that and then that was a few months
later I was doing interview with him in
Warsaw during the rapid and Blitz World
Championship and he jumped in and she
said you promised me to play here and
you still keep asking me questions so we
had lots of fun with that hands and
hands and brain a variant of chess for
those of you don't know it so the idea
is you play as a team yes so uh for
example Anastasia might be the brain and
she'll say to me night or night yes and
I'm restricted I can only move whatever
she said if she said Bishop there's only
one Bishop on the board then it's pretty
easy what I but if there's two Bishops
right and I make the wrong bishop move
then the brain gives me a very nasty
dirty look like what do you think you're
doing exactly yeah
beautifully yes I like this variation of
Chess it is and another question from
social media is
lavorg
Giovanni uh so the question is I used to
be a subscriber of Yasser Vernal inside
chess I love the game commentary and the
other stuff any hope to sit back well
first of all thank you so much for your
support I loved inside chess magazine we
published it for 12 years and I wrote
all these editorial wheels and telling
about the world interviews and it just
it was a very very special time but it
was all
pre-internet
so when the internet came along it just
destroyed newspapers it destroyed
magazines today I'm really questioning
how these magazines and newspapers
survive Because the Internet is just so
full of everything instantly now keep in
mind that our Journal came out every two
weeks and by the time it came out it was
already old the news was two two three
four five weeks old so I don't think any
journals are coming back but I love the
web uh today and you know you can get
these stories one of my favorite places
to go is chessbase.com I love chess base
I love the articles on chess.com and I
just feel like I'm up to date not only
you know with the latest week but the
latest hour yeah it's just incredible
and there's no way that paper can keep
up with digital but still it's a little
bit I still like to read books yeah
paper me too I like the tactiles I mean
yeah but yes for being a subscriber yeah
I remember I was just on a I was just on
a flight uh coming here to St Louis and
the lady next to me she had one of those
tablets e-readers and this e-reader was
really nice like this e-reader was just
the screen the colored everything it was
like it was a pleasure reading over her
shoulder right and I asked her you know
about her e-reader she said oh she has
about 2 000 books
on the e-reader and I was thinking to
myself okay if each book was a half a
kilo
to carry all of those books with you and
this is not possible it's remarkable
for example she really enjoys reading a
book yes like many many years she has it
and because she told me before she would
carry like 10 20 books you also read
positives no no I meant caring yes
I was a mule I mean it was terrible
uh Christian what has got your eye I see
Favi as on your board absolutely and
Fabiano is a motivated young man right
now take a look at what happened Knight
to E5 we were considering Rook to E8 as
well and then of course after Bishop to
F4 Knight to E5 it does seem like the
position simplifies and the most likely
result is going to be a draw but take a
look at Fabiano's move B5 whoa
you're also attacking the bishop at the
same time C4 is coming in the position
if you take on D6 I take on D3 attacking
the bishop only two you take with one of
your pieces Queen to B6 is coming you're
losing at the Knight on D6 you're going
to be a piece down so we understand that
most likely Sam Savion understands that
as well but right now what are you going
to do if you don't take on a B5 because
B4 is coming take it take it oh you
still want to take it yeah and after C4
Knight F2 Knight to F2 and this is the
key position most likely in fact we're
probably going to go into this line but
after Bishop to C5 I mean I probably
have to go back right because Knight D4
is a threat yes 94 might be a threat in
the position yes uh Bishop takes C4 oh
really I want to go Queen F2 uh Queen C2
to protect my all right all right
everything comes with tempo right now
once again wow yeah yeah yeah to G4 is
coming also Knight fg4 and guess what
I'm actually checkmating you Queen to H4
is coming wow wow wow so I don't think
you want to capture that one in the
position I I don't think first of all I
can also go this night no no no no I
don't want to take and allow 90 E5 and
Knight G4 no no I was taking you can in
order to play Queen C2 and to uh
1940 yes
that's the problem in the position you
can go Bishop to F4 but yeah now I can
just take on F2 if I want I can take on
C4 and then take on F2 if I want and
this position is just not good for you
because everything comes with Tempo even
after you take take take I still have
Queen B6 and Bishop twice yes you still
have problems in the position
it's very unfortunate okay the geometry
Works in Black's favor despite the fact
that sure maybe you do have two Pawns
for the exchange is not enough your king
is actually extremely exposed then right
now Fabiano with the black pieces I mean
if he wins this one he's going to be
taking a commanding lead of the event
wow B5 yes
I thought A6 was you know to prevent uh
Knight B5 not to support a B5 just
taking a look at the game between a
wonder and Sam I love White's position I
don't say it's winning or anything like
that it's just one of those nights
versus Bishop's position where you have
a pass Pawn I have a pass Pawn but your
past Pawn is firmly blockaded by this
beautiful night on D4 and if I could
ever get a situation where I'm just
playing with a single rook and Knight
against single rook and Bishop I'll get
an active King I can win this game very
very easily as white Sam England even
though it's material balance I think
well I'm certain I would like to play
this position as white feeling like I do
have I'm the one with winning chances
let's take a look at our second coming
into the into the round today Ray Robson
thanks to back-to-back victories very
very impressive victories too by Ray uh
he's playing against elshon our U.S open
champion elshon
in in a kind of a tumble I want to say
and we'll quickly catch up with the
players we left it here and here's where
I was saying that you know
even though black has achieved more or
less all of his goals out of the opening
I still like White's position Maybe
threads so Bishop takes D3 maybe yes
potential yeah
this three was it is a little bit weak
if black will manage to attack it yes so
now actually he found a way but now what
now what is white indeed yes B5 do you
want to play B5 I'm sure right I'm not
sure either uh well one of the things I
would uh definitely want to do is play a
little bit tricky uh the idea behind
Queen B3 is please take my Pawn yes
yes now you should know Anastasia I
never sacrificed the phone I mean I I
have a nasty idea in mind which is Queen
takes D3 and queen takes E6 check you
don't take the pawn but if you don't
take the pawn if you Castle this is
where I was hoping that some good
goodies might fall into my lap after a
move like D3 yeah reason the fact that
90s precisely that's exactly what I was
hoping for so maybe Queen B3 as opposed
to day five B5 mate shut things down
yeah I don't like this move I I just was
thinking what what how to defend this
Pawn yesterday I think this tree looks
much better yeah maybe you have also
Queen A2 but Queen this year looks
better because you also defend your Rook
right and also support all the moves I
want uh Victor korchnoy once went into a
50-minute thing where he played Queen B3
after this long thing and I asked Victor
my God 50 minutes what were you thinking
he said I was thinking about Queen A2
so it's the same idea but there's those
subtle differences in one case you play
to defend your rook in another case you
play for A5 yes and to try to attack the
bishop on A6 and he spent all of this
time uh trying to understand the very
subtle differences between the two moves
so I said well how did you finally make
your decision he said I flipped the coin
you're in your mind like yeah mentally
but the Korean get out of here no you go
away go away go away it's not a bad way
to make your own mind right I mean if
you really don't know what to play I
mean you just kind of ask luck yeah Lady
Luck what do you what do you do uh let's
see uh in the trailing pack of players
we were looking at the game between
Wesley so our defending Champion against
darouch darouch all them and vigor went
G5 G4 Knight G1 and we got here in our
mine Queen E8 and I was playing Knight
H2 Queen E2 and I was playing for F4
with my king
when they speak yes one of the most
active pieces in the position The Rook
Rook also on F3 uh
uh Wesley started with uh Queen E2 and
we'll see if we see Queen G6 and that F4
action that uh okay that might be asking
a a bridge too far but we'll keep an eye
on that one Christian back over to you
what do you have for us I'm looking at
this game between uh Tate and Talia and
um
thought they've actually played this
move F5 so we were recommending the move
Queen to C5 once again it's all about
the pin uh on the f8 A3 diagonal and you
can get rid of that with the move Queen
to C5 not only that but you're setting
up an immediate threat of Rook takes F6
she did not do that she played the move
F5 which we were seeing in a lot of our
lines previously right this idea of F5
you take on F5 and then I go Knight to
D4 activate the knight at the same time
with Tempo I'm going to get the Knight
to F5 you're busted at this point so you
cannot play like this but check this out
Talia understood the position understood
the fact that she can take advantage of
this pin and play the move King to f8
this wouldn't be possible with a queen
on C5 the queen protected on C5 because
of Rook takes F6 but unfortunately Queen
takes before right now doesn't work so
you have to do something at this point
and King to f8 sets up
A Minor Threat in the position that is
to attack this Rook on D6 and transition
into an end game after FTX G6 Knight to
E8 seems to be the best move now you
have to go a rook to B6 Queen takes B4
Rook takes B4 I pick back up uh the pawn
on G6 and how do we assess this Vision
how easy is this position for y to
convert her Advantage because there's
definitely an advantage yes The Rook on
B4 is quite active after the move C5 I'm
both attacking the pawn on e4 and the
pawn on B7 I still have a lot of threats
in the position the move that you
mentioned as well Anastasia Bishop takes
A6 after this move C5 but how easy it is
because I will go Knight to C7 I will
defend this guy if I manage to set up my
pieces go King to G7 Rook behind the
pawn on E8 things might start looking
good for black so I'm not sure if tatv
found the right path in the position and
Talia definitely trying right now to uh
defend this very very difficult opening
that she got now let's take a look at
what's happening in the ashrita game
Megan
I'm not going to go for a very long time
because Megan did find the move King to
G2 makes a lot of sense she took by the
way the Knight on e4 of course F5 came
to G2 and this is the variation that we
were looking at from afar take only four
I defend against your Rook to F2 right
you exchange take and queen to B2 this
is what we have right now but what if I
just hide my king you're nothing
anywhere right this bishop is coming to
uh G2 I have full control over the light
scores you are not promoting uh this
e-pawn anytime soon not at all
she played
I can just simply go uh D6 I can you
because I play Rook F2
[Laughter]
okay and actually I picked this guy up
and pick on E3 up as well so I take you
go here I think I can take what about
day one yes okay
you take I go here and you don't have
Queen to F2 Check Yes it's important yes
I mean Queen Street it's nice to this is
losing also this is nice movie so pretty
much everything is losing at this point
I mean I can also start with the move
Rook to B1 if I really want to I would
assume you're going to go Queen to A2
try to keep this yeah on the second leg
but once again the same problem D6 uh in
the position I think I have other ideas
as well maybe even Queen to E1 take
control of the F2 uh Square uh but D6 is
just the easiest path to victory in this
position exactly and if she wins I mean
guys
she's taking a very serious lead unless
Irina Crush manages to keep Pace by
beating Sophie Mori Suzuki and it does
seem likely that that result will come
on the board as well because I realize
having a crushing Advantage at this
moment really can we check your game
actually just to make sure what's going
on absolutely the leaders we were
discussing we asked and answered
Christian tell us what arena is doing
well we were discussing this position
she still hasn't gotten her Pawn back
but that's just taking your time she's
taking her time but that point is going
to fall right if you try to defend it
with Bishop to F5 well first of all you
have some problems on the E file uh
right now that are being set up with
this move Rook fe1 but also you're
losing the pawn on p7 once you lose the
pawn on B7 that's bad this B Pawn is
going to be not Unstoppable but you're
going to have to sacrifice give up some
material uh to stop it from promoting
that's not good news so you cannot do
that you cannot play the move Bishop to
F5 you can try to hold on to your Pawn
but again I'm not even in a hurry it's
all about uh the peace activity the and
the difference uh between whites and
black species Bishop to business is one
way Bishop to D4 is one way Bishop to F4
you have big problems defending and
finding the right spot for the
bishopone7 and I'm coming with Tempo if
you go Bishop to D6 I will go 51 I'm
going to pick up the pawn on D3 with
tempo right on the bishop on D6 you
don't finish your development anytime
soon and this might be problematic for
your position no mites about it it
absolutely is a terribly Pro uh
problematic in fact
um
sorry this is not the game yeah so we
have two leaders who might actually win
yeah
absolutely sorry I it was fabi's game
that I wanted to ask a Christian about
now now again a knight takes B5 uh this
Knight takes B5 C4 Knight F2 Bishop C5
this is like a very awkward uh situation
this uh pin you're obviously threatening
Knight E4 and it's actually really
really curious that after this move King
H1 you know you uh there was a double
attack in a recent game I where Megan
could have played G4 and the loud Knight
takes G4 and then there was a Queenie
too again
with a double attack that's nice I mean
this is actually a kind of an unusual
well unless you play a lot of benoni
positions a nice double attack the
desirable King H1 walks into Queen B6
it's the Knight has been lured to the
square B5 Sam is taking a lot of time uh
for a good reason for a good reason for
B5 because I assume the alternative
Christian is if you can't take the pawn
you have to just pull in your horns and
play a move like Bishop F4 and then how
was the evaluation better position uh
better for black already better yeah
black already has a pretty significant
Advantage actually
uh B5 C takes B5 a takes B5 was actually
uh the wrong direction so
maybe before it's coming why before it's
coming yes very good yeah yeah so you're
not immediately of course not
immediately yes but after Bishop to F4
we exchange those Bishops but at this
point he was not supposed to take on a
B5 so it's better we should have played
Bishop Bishop F4 yeah and now B4 uh
doesn't have the same sting in the
position because my opponent D5 is
protected by the pawn on C4 right and
that's a big difference you probably
have to take on C4 yes there's no sync
to this move before you exactly much
worse perhaps he will split way in a
planning at the beginning to take the
spot surely
he started to understand the position is
not so great and it's too late right
after you already took on B5 exactly
well you can understand it if you if you
play the most C4 takes B5 a takes B5 uh
suddenly this Rook is doing a job B5 B4
is annoying now that the Rook has opened
up C4 is potentially very annoying as
well as moves like Knight C5 and queen
B6 could come with check so if you not
going to take on B5 yes the very
important point is don't play start with
C4 takes B5 but start with the move
Bishop F4 and I suspect that probably
even fake
yeah and but the inclusion of that trade
highly favorable for Fabi and what is
the evaluation for Fabiano and right now
uh the computer is giving almost a plus
one point Advantage wow it's a it's a
big Advantage the way the best moves yes
in the hands of a surging Fabiano I mean
minus one advantage uh you don't want to
be in that position absolutely and
Fabiano is a leader we can see the
currency
will he be able to increase his lead to
more points especially now that he plays
against sand that's what I wanted to ask
and I wanted to ask you about this as
well Christian so Ray Robson power to
him has crossed that 2700 uh brings
himself into that class of very very
elite players but with this massive plus
four score what is faby's tpr tournament
performance that is a great question I
think it's closer 2900 that's my guess
yes that is my guess it should be very
close to 2 900. so buddy we made the
2700 results Abby says let me try up
that and I'll take a 2900 result if you
don't mind my asking and he did not
capture on B5 and he did not play Bishop
F4 no he played seven three played
Bishop E3 there's there's an accident in
the T right there oh oh
immediately addressed by Fabiano yes uh
did he take the tea challenge and
was he the board was it
imagine what
um
and Ray
wow that's me uh you know when you talk
about conquering Mount Everest and you
think about uh Magnus Carlson's goal of
becoming the first player to ever cross
the 2900 barrier and to have a
performance like Fabi is having that
Magnus would require this type of
performance to meet his goal and not on
one event in one event you have to keep
doing it for some time in order to look
amazing
28.92 uh we'll keep an eye if Abby does
even more successfully and uh wins today
that uh would go up really really
remarkable uh so far but uh Anastasia
I'm thinking it's time for a break yes
let's have a coffee and tea too let's
join the party we'll see you on the
other side of the break
thank you
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
United States
the St Louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant Central West End has
established itself as a premier Global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profit institutions
the chess club and Scholastic Center of
St Louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays hosts to
all major tournaments including the U.S
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand Masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of Chess to
Children throughout the St Louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing Scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 Schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the World Chess Hall of
Fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the U.S and World Chess Halls
of Fame
Cutting Edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art Innovative programming
explores the intersection of Chess art
and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries the World
Chess Hall of Fame is nothing you expect
and everything you love three different
Galleries and a premier gift shop
highlight the culture history and
creativity Behind The Game come visit
play chess leave enriched to learn more
about the St Louis chess campus visit
stlchesscampus.org
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you
thank you
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and welcome back everyone and we have a
result yes
Sam Shanklin did a very nice exchange
sacrifice in the position that I didn't
like for him yes I wonder allowed and
then returned the exchange sacrifice and
our first result of the day oops that's
not the game but this is the this is
this was the ending it was the Knight
versus Bishop ending and I guess the
players really felt that there wasn't
much in it for white but I would tend to
want to disagree a little bit you want
to play Rook to C3 King F2 and maintain
the Knight but uh this was the exchange
sacrifice that I liked by Sam right here
he just said you know what yes I'll go
here and do your worst uh this bishop is
anchored to the pawn on F7 and uh Wonder
said well I'll give back the exchange
and let's make a draw today the the two
professionals discovered a three move
repetition and a first draw of round
eight yes and we have the first result
um so the other games still continue we
don't have results in women's
there either uh the fobby game is with
all the pieces on the board definitely
very very interesting game but in truth
a really really nice position I think
for Fabi uh his you know his every move
like this Rook comes to the open file he
did it with a gain of tempo Sam had to
drop back with the bishop I'm
anticipating I like this Pawn on B5 I
don't want to push it like to maintain
it and I like to maintain it with the
move Bishop A6 myself I start to think
about moves like B5 B4 uh and also
following it with Queen B8 it just feel
feels like everything is going in
Black's favor and I'm not really too
sure what white is doing I feel like I'm
probably for the next 10 moves I'm going
to be nursing uh this this Pawn on D5
trying to hold it
right away
if I still played before you know I
cannot wait before yesterday
impatient yes okay
um well I mean
I mean you have to take probably right
maybe 95. and the problem is I I'm
afraid Ana says he is that I'll lead my
E2 Bishop vulnerable in this case
because there's Rook remember it came it
it you gained a Tempo with that last
move rookie eight I probably have to
explain that before right away yeah
jumping and the bishop is hanging so I
have to move the bishop on the faith you
want to be aggressive or do you want to
no not immediately and then I can maybe
uh support the pawn right but if on this
night on before if you all of those
ideas that you're having of playing B5
pardon me B4 and Knight takes D5 once
you see how you can play B Bishop A6
Queen and you don't allow the Knight to
go to B5 you know I mean that's my
source of counter play yes I'm convinced
yes you have to wait a little bit with
all this aggressive you should prepare
them and this is actually what good
players they do but I I mean you're
building up this initiative you're
putting your pieces on all of these
great uh squares and who knows even like
if we're just putting another move on
the board for just a moment if I just
did something really kind of silly you
can start to see another problem
emerging do you find
yeah that
um again just a few more moves and you
can start to see how vulnerable this
Pawn on D5 is I don't like this for Sam
if uh if he finds a way of
um
how do you say pulling the parachute and
trading off some pieces uh count his
lucky stars it's not a easy position Ray
Robson versus elshon jumping into that
game well when we left it we just did
leave it at this moment before Rook d8
B5 not Queen B3 but he did it the next
turn Okay first but then decided to play
Queen and G3
A5 takes takes
we've caught up with the players
um
not so sure that uh White's last few
moves make an impression unless I can
stir up some trouble with A5 the king is
still however temporary the king is
still in the center but
I'm not convinced that so you cannot
take on this three no because then C4 or
I don't know uh the the first question
was Rook takes and then Queen B5 check
into seven the queen D7 second question
is if can I just threaten to make a
queen
B7 if you will
um but so I can take it
C takes B6 let's say queen takes B6 it's
really scary
yes taking one more right ask the
question Bishop takes well Rook takes
yes I hear that you are enjoying your
position ah no I can't play rookie eight
but I can't believe it okay seven
unfortunately I don't like it or Knight
D2 but Rook A7 Queen is six or what yes
I'm trying still yes no no no no good
for you uh hang in there hang in there
okay let's try to be creative what if I
take on C5 now
[Music]
I say evil intentions as well yes yes
that looks pretty good to me uh
Christian but yeah you can play A5 yeah
so by the way that's exactly what we do
uh is we analyze all the captures in the
most forcing moves first
because if they work yes then it is
brilliant when they don't work then we
have to come up with some other plan I'm
thinking that if I'm in ratios I don't
want to open up the position when my
king is still in the center so I would I
would likely shy towards this move B5
trying to keep the position closed as
soon as some sort of a threat right
maybe even Rook takes D3 is a threat
right now yeah so if I play a Batman an
mc4 yeah yeah I would like to do this
especially when my king is safely
ensconced but yeah and you're probably
right because now you have nice things
right I just happen to have that tactic
although five
wow
okay Rook takes D3 is a bit too much
but we have to hurry with Rolex D3 yeah
yeah no but just to purchase
but yes I I if I'm in ratios uh B6 B5 uh
might be my way of just keeping things
under control for the next little while
Christian back over to you what has
caught your eye well I'm looking at this
game and I'm still trying to understand
Christopher's happened the game between
Christopher you and Jeffrey Zhang this
position already does feel like it's a
bit better for black because you cannot
get to my pawns and I will get uh to the
base of your Pawn chain the pawn on G5 I
will go Rook to H4 next Rook to H2 Rook
to G2 I have a lot of ways to get to
your a G5 pawn and my base the pawn on
F7 is nicely protected by the Knight
right now take a look at this move
C4 what by Christopher you mean that's
exactly what Jeffrey did he took the
pawn instantaneously take on C4 Bishop
Knight takes C4 Knight to C5 this is the
current position that we have right now
but what if I just go Knight D6
defending once again Defender B7 right
yeah Rook D7 57 as well as the pawn on
episode
maybe this is what he missed but even
this is better after Rook 31 Rook to E8
or King to D6 even allow you to take on
D7 and then activate it into D5 this is
good also but what if I just go Knight
D6 you go rookie one I go rookie eight
right and how do we assess this end game
I guess Rook to E7 has to be uh checked
because you do get the pawn on the
seventh rank but after B6 94 98 Knight
F6 I can go into the same game and I
lost two passers yeah well I have one
passer and I will create the second one
right on the C file in the meantime I
just go King E8 and there's no way you
were going to promote anytime soon so
yeah it's puzzling decision for me uh to
see this move C4 by Christopher you and
right now after Knight to D6 I have a
feeling he's just going to take his head
in his hands uh maybe start shaking his
head I mean he realizes right now that
things went South very quickly and you
don't have any counter chances after 96.
yes exactly well this is one of the
things that I always loved about the
Karo Khan is that it's this rather
provocative
defense and we saw that Christopher went
for Jeffrey F5 G5 H4 and he was pushing
the king side with uh abandon but now
he's just pushed too hard and with this
Pawn
sacrifice this loss of the pawn
Christopher's in trouble I wanted to
turn our attention to our defending
Champion Wesley versus darouche because
this was actually a very interesting
game especially if we go back to this
point right here we see this move uh G5
G4 it makes a very visual impression
that black is really going gangbusters
on the king side but as we flash to the
game and we update the game you'll start
to see that all of these attackers
there's no attack and and there are some
weaknesses in Black's Camp check this
out Rook G1
Rook F3 and King G2 okay and now you see
white actually has a very solid uh
everybody's defending
yeah well maybe you get under and you go
all the way over I'm actually thinking
the king is rather safe and that what
you want to do actually is play Rook to
H1 and Rook to H4 and then at the end of
the day you start saying to Black hahaha
your Pawn on H5 is really really weak
and you'll be forced to defend it so you
went from this really great attacking
you know yes now you have to
pull in your horns a little bit and you
and you don't just trade off that
weakness either I mean that would be a
very bad very very very bad idea is to
open up the position against your king
let's see and what's happening in the
ladies is Megan completely winning when
we left it you certainly was yes she is
she still is
um age four was played G takes H4 she's
saying you want to give me another Pawn
sure I'll take it why not yeah yes okay
too again where is your attack as black
where is your compensation I will go
rookie two Bishop G2 and that's
resignation absolutely um
what is ashrita's plan yes now it's just
let's say 94 probably should just kind
of missed something miscalculated there
it was it was a he looked to F2 but I
mean Rook to F2 I just simply take
[Music]
Queen F3
Queen F3 is also over in the move yeah
yeah yeah
I mean you're attacking me with your
bear Queen yes
in the game between
Alex
Domingo says this game finished in the
draw yes uh apologies to the players who
really didn't follow the game because
frankly it was a lot of theory
upon sacrifice for good compensation and
and Lanier pardon me uh Alexander
couldn't do anything a draw was the
result no this game definitely Megan is
uh for sure going to win I mean barring
a massive accident Katarina keep
um B7 yes before pay attention that she
married that was a very big success yes
we like needs to do something so she
decided to give up the spawn and finish
for development but of course as you
said yes sir once white get this phone
yeah it's so bad
I feel like things have improved a
little bit for black have they
especially after Bishop D3 let's say
yes finally the bishop only seven has a
Target it has that pawn on A3 right
right
um it was funny because the first move I
was looking at was Rook C1 but you can
take my queen and then take the pawn
let's calculate that how do we feel
about that position I'm I'm not a fan
let's try Queen D2 so Bishop takes B5
I've got Queen D5 check right there's no
check
yes I already
it's okay yes we're matching today yes
one one for one yes uh that's annoying
just a second hold on hold on hold on
that's annoying so A4 Queen so simple
right Queen F1
she could have played Queen D5 this was
the move I was kind of beating the drum
for uh earlier I I know we got a
position similar to this where I just
thought you know White's pieces were
more active but Queen C3 that's annoying
that's very annoying uh Sophie didn't
get the message that she was you must
comply yes I think Queen's history is
quite a good move it's a good move so
actually if you play Rook C1 now do we
have like even Queen A1
that's a blindness on my partner I just
thought about it that maybe it's not
possible
your tactics yes my puzzle Russia okay
uh Queen H3 in that case so the
difference is is that I'm not going to
get a check on E6 but maybe yeah
I can uh
yes what to play after Bishop before
Queen H3 now A3 is hanging
and by the way I don't know if I have a
Tempo to hit your Bishop because let's
take on A3 right as you were saying uh
A1 is hanging Rook takes E7 would walk
into something nasty
um
okay let's see if she's going to play
Bishop D3 she's just about to make a
move Sophie it's Sophie okay let's see
what can I do to make your life a little
Bishop data is on the board
right
[Laughter]
no Queen H3 Bishop takes A3 and I'm
looking for a good move for arena has
she spoiled her Advantage
um at least partially yes she spoiled
her advantage and right now she let's
see what she has to do specifically in
this position
um actually in fact The Rook ec1 is the
best move surprisingly and if you do
take here Queen takes D3 apparently is
just really good for uh White I'm trying
to understand why white is it this end
game and the B Pawn is just too powerful
yes it seems like the B Pawn is actually
more powerful than a mixed change a full
exchange wow so bishop and B5 Pawn out
duel the B6 B7 and then that's going to
be problematic
um so this is a big moment and by the
way psychologically to play Rook ec1 is
not easy yes because you lose an
exchange you know that and it's very
difficult to assess the ensuing end game
you can only play it if you miss it yeah
because you want then your opponent take
only one and actually it's not so bad
you know like yes I missed it but it's
not that bad and what if she goes Queen
H3 right yes yeah Bishop takes A3 yeah
Bishop Texas her Advantage actually has
uh dissipated what about Bishop base
seven I was thinking about yeah they're
trying to find the way how to
go after this but you're not pushing the
pawn because yes Bishop C6 is hanging um
you cannot move the Bishop from C6
because you lose the pawn on B5 right so
I keep the bishop on D3 I control the
movement of uh your Rooks with this
combination of the queen on C3 attacking
both Rooks as well as the two Bishops
controlling every single Square except
the one you cannot even give up your
Rook on this week exactly exactly you
cannot do this I was thinking yes maybe
I should already give this by the way
Queen H3 is on the board okay Queen H3
is on the ball and we expect Bishop
takes A3 it makes a lot of sense right
and for the standings should Arena not
score Megan is definitely winning I mean
she's a full piece up and the safe King
and she's going to go to Six she will be
the sole leader if Arena only makes a
draw or uh Jennifer is sitting there
saying okay I need to win and bounce
back by the way and in the open section
what has happened so far I think we have
two results
as well as a Wonderland together with
Sam Shanklin and we think that Fabi is
actually enjoying a nice advantage and
three results possible in the elshon
versus Ray Robson game but I think Ray
might actually prefer his chances at
this exact moment by the way thank you
for joining the conversation it's always
nice to have an active audience love
your participation and we have some
questions from social media questions
yes we do no not from Ben Feingold
you knew this was coming you got
disrespected he's got this perspectives
sorry Ben didn't mean any disrespect by
your never plays F6 horrors of Horrors
thank you for watching the show Ben I
love your stream by the way I'm a big
big big fan not about F6 though
I have everything in life and another
question uh Anastasia this one is from
Dr tulo fonseco I wonder what are those
green arm resting parts of the game
tables made of can someone uh help you
yeah the the sets that you see at the
boards these are handmade from a local
Furniture maker here in St Louis and
what they are literally resting pads so
you have this kind of like a soft felt
so that in this posture we've got your
elbows sometimes you can bruise your
elbows
yes like this here this padding is
really really nice and I remember
visiting the Buenos Iris chess club in
Buenos Aires Argentina and waiting to do
a symbol and I was sitting at a table a
chess table that I thought was
magnificent that had leather
arm rests on it and the table had a
little insert so you could literally
bring your belly into the board on both
sides and there was a place where you
could pull open a drawer and there was a
cigar uh place that you could drop your
cigar
ette they just thought this was the
nicest chest table in the whole world
that I'd ever sat at and it was the
world championship
capablanca versus Alexander alakine at
the Buenos Aires chess club I was just
sitting there and they said yes it were
you we're upstairs on the second floor I
said it was in here for somebody to pick
me up and I was literally at the world
championship match table nice it was
really really wonderful so you found
your dream table the table yes if they
ever wanted to imitate a table that's
the one to do it I really felt and in
literally a place for the cognac a
little place for the cigar it was cool
everything together everything you could
ever want uh wow at a chess board and
one more well many questions okay thank
you very much everybody thank you this
one is from dagger D Cabrera yeah but
nice question actually how do you
approach side lines you are unfamiliar
with in the opening okay so this is
tough this is possible for you to to
have any sideline you're right in fact
it's those Sidelines that I personally
as a professional chess player found so
attractive because Mainline you just you
just have to expect everybody knows
everything right through the main line
but those Sidelines can be really really
tricky and I I know that an interview
Fabi talked about this as well is that
those Sidelines were the engines you
know kind of like they don't care for it
that much you can really find some great
traps and provided that you didn't make
you know some egregious mistake and
you're not taking too big a risk you can
really trick your opponent now the
question is I'm on the other side I get
surprised somebody plays a sideline
against me I literally do this I stop
take a deep breath and I just ask myself
did I make any mistakes here up to this
moment if everything I did was natural
and logical I'm not going to be punished
I didn't do anything that was terrible
that I should be punished so it's it's
how you train yourself how about
yourself Anastasia how did you approach
Sidelines it's like a challenge in a way
also right I mean so you go out of the
book you have to find just moves you
have to just play the game the way it is
and I mean it's of course you don't like
the situation maybe that your opponent
knows better right the position yes but
on the other hand okay you literally you
should just keep fighting I mean that's
important and let's let's not fear come
to the board as well exactly you have to
be still like optimistic about your
understanding of the position
um Christian jump in yeah coach
definitely you shouldn't uh panic and
one strategy that I always tell my
students to maybe adopt is especially if
your position is healthy and this is a
great point that you made Yasser if you
have made any bad looking moves if your
chest has been looking beautiful up to
that point it means your position most
likely is healthy so there shouldn't be
any worries in the position now what you
should do if you feel like you uh have
been caught in some sort of opening
preparation make an awkward move a move
that maybe your opponent did not
anticipate in his preparation take him
out of the book and try to play uh face
to face over the board without any
engine assistance without any previous
engine assistance so this is the type of
potential strategy that you could adopt
to deal with unfamiliar sidelines
thank you for that Chris and very very
good advice I just want to turn our
attention to elshon versus Ray nobody
wants to jump on elshon al-shan having a
a bad event he played this move somehow
kind of a disharmony up to this moment
uh I kind of felt that elshon was
actually to be preferred pardon me it
was without the move B5 I liked elshon's
position here
the last few moves somehow they don't
really fit together after a5b5 Knight F5
okay it's a very transparent threat of
Queen takes E6 check and Knight takes G7
and Ray just said okay I'll Dodge the
threat now what are you going to do
okay Queen C2 so all of that early you
know I'm making a threat I'm making a
threat I'm making threat well I don't
have anything to do well excuse me but
you're the one who played G3 I have a
light squared Bishop who you know whose
King is suddenly weaker yes King h8 it
starts to it starts to ask some
questions you know Queen H5 uh could be
coming on the board G6 kick the Knight
away so D3 D4 and we're catching up to
the players but I'm really liking how
the game is opening up for Rey uh in
this position absolutely and there's a
big move right now that he should
probably find and that is Queen to H5
yes winter H5 the one you proposed yes
that is the big one yes so let's see if
you plug into two okay King G2
I have finished something is with
geometry
I was looking at something like Queen G4
and Knight F4 ideas but maybe yes but
now you've now you've kind of uh
made me start thinking about other ideas
I like once Rook takes on D4 for example
in some variations so you want to play
Queen of three and but okay that's a
very good point so well why you can
start with G6 maybe six yes
yes and then just take on D4 isn't that
just the pawn
an author Knight D5 I think Bishop B7 is
also coming I mean the long deck well
that was up and that was the dream come
true I mean if this bishop ever
positions itself on this long diagonal
you're really going to regret G3 and
King G2 at least those combination of
moves and it feels like after Queen H5
and by the way you did play the move G6
was Queen G4 I mean it's kind of a
trappy tricky it's very nice yeah if you
go H3 you go neither four yes well
that's immediate uh lights out that's
the nice
yeah sorry yes it's the same you're
almost aren't you
aren't you almost forced to go back
maybe 91 yeah Queen H5 is on the board
found by Rey with how much time on his
clock ten minutes
wow that's a real Luxury 10 whole
minutes for Ray yes
and how many moves he's getting better
and better faster and faster
23 okay that's not that crazy
this is a luxury okay
um let's uh jump to Fabiano and Sam
saviano and again let's give Sam some
credit here he's up against our
tournament leader but Sam has gone
through this entire tournament
undefeated and not a lot of people are
saying that at this moment I mean this
is a tough event oh by the way we got
here and Fabi loved your idea before but
he prepped it yes he did Play the movie
First bishop F3 B4 and C4 okay
that means surprise uh
what C for how about them Apple C for
night to say Rook takes
Knight takes
wow and I take so there's three
recaptures you can capture with the
Queen Bishop or Knight
wow okay he said by recapturing with the
Knight he's saying essentially tonight
E5 is what it's about
yeah 94
and Bishop E5 B2 is is hanging mm-hmm
Bishop to D4 defending Bishop to B7
and we've caught up with the players wow
some high class yes for looting moves
going on here Christian
as Sam well Sam's kept the material
balance he's still still worse he still
works the defending side yeah he
improved his chances yeah that was my
question he's getting closer and closer
to liquidating more and more pieces sets
of pieces and that's going to take him
closer to uh equality but it's still not
easy and especially with how much time
does he have on the clock eight minutes
and 45 seconds that's not a lot it isn't
but uh help us navigate the waters here
after Bishop B7 Sam is looking at this
Pawn on D Phi D5 under attack
um you know at first you you want to do
something with the Rook you want to
somehow uh play a move like Bishop H5
but Bishop takes D5 is just a
showstopper and perhaps Let's uh
let's go King H1 let's improve the
position a little bit King H1 just to
get off this all these checks and
challenges
Bishop takes King H1 Bishop takes
um if you take I want to recapture with
the Knight and defend the bishop with
the queen correct luckily I have
something in the game right now
D6 ah I thought you were going before
taking on E5 yes before taking on E5
so we're not exchanging the Bishops
Knight D6 immediately yes yes 96 is
whoa there's some some tactics in the
position okay and then like Bishop D6
Bishop D5 F7 is hanging yesterday
this is spectacularly good you look at
this you sacrificed upon for the
initiative now you're so happy you're
happy you're very very happy and if you
do it the other way Bishop takes F3 then
Queen takes F3 and F7 is hanging you
cannot touch the Knight because in this
case G7 is a Checkmate but these are not
easy tactics to see to spawn King age
one
it's a great example wow of prophylactic
to to my eyes Queen to D2 makes the most
sense but before we get into the depths
of this position let's go to Megan Lee
because I think she's about to win
well that has been the case for quite
some time since a shritha played the
whoa
there's nowhere I'm not sure how did
those pawns get uh loud
but Queen takes
E3 is kind of automatic isn't it here
now yes oh yeah get rid of those guys
before they go any further Queen takes
E3 and there's nothing to play for this
is over this is over unless you find
some sort of a stalemate but you have
something
yes without phone number six maybe
no okay we could be expecting a
handshake but then again we've been
calling this game for some time I was
thinking what happened to our small girl
let's sleep yes sir at the same time
this was the game uh Naji sacrificed a
pawn in the center counter early and
then she actually exchanges Exchange in
Queens and just to move to this ending
and I wonder like what about descending
well is it so good yes she's got a dream
right plant the night on F6 and it'll
all turn out well D5 to stop Alice said
no I see that oh interesting I might
have been more tempted to play the move
Bishop B5 my yourself to get the
imbalance
G5 G5 okay she's trying it's trying to
get a stalemate going yes let me uh go
with Megan okay let's try to find
astounding I mean we know is it's not
going to happen it's very unlikely that
it's going to happen but let's try to
find it Well I mean I won't fall for
your stalemate what I'll do is force the
trade I understand that yes oh sorry we
know how to win this
but do you coach coach
you have to win this position okay we're
trying to find the style well she's
trying to find a mate yes I can tell you
to give all the time checks no stalemate
for sure okay I found the stalemate guys
yeah okay work this out so go ahead King
G7 queen queen G7 I'm going to take on
G5 okay okay beautiful you play F1 F1
yes and now you take with a king yes and
now I go Queen D3 I'm like ah I forgot
about the fact that you can take with
the bishop on them yes
wow boy that was a lot of cooperation I
gotta say that was more cooperation than
uh
no but you know there is this um there
are such puzzles Cooperative checkmates
yes like you have to find the way how to
get the chicken exactly I don't know if
you ever tried this kind of stuff
housemates or something self-made
self-made yeah
Cooperative yes Cooperative cooperative
uh Queen uh well hold on just a second
she went Queen E8 did she have a
checkmate
does she have a checklist she played
Queen G8 Queen G8 and King to H6 is King
H6
how can there not be a force Checkmate
here that just would be so unfair uh we
take it
H5 King H5 Bishop F7 we draw the king or
Bishop to E2
but you always have this King twitch for
how do we not have a Checkmate maybe
King H3 allow enough one now I found
another stem
change the Queens by force how do we
exchange the Queens by force yes
I don't like my stalemate
three okay chemistry threatening me yes
F1 yeah okay because you want Bishop B2
Checkmate right and then maybe just
three that is beautiful yes that is nice
it will never happen
[Laughter]
finally we got the done deal and Megan
said well I'm gonna give up my attempts
to Checkmate your king but I will uh
trade Queens instead and that was our
congratulations to Megan and she propels
herself thanks to this Victory clear
first let's jump back to the open
section and check in on Christopher and
Jeffrey Zhang uh Jeffrey has been
collecting ponds very very nicely we
left it he had won one
right about here and got into a night
ending where he decided
it was a good idea to take another one
yes why not
and two extra Pawns
and well this is just too easy
Yes actually it's gonna be his first
Victory yes of course I know because I'm
following him closely it's my pick ah
yes yes yes yes
well I mean I can feel uh Jeffrey
nothing like a victory Digger to really
fill your Ambitions but this is hopeless
I mean I'm really wondering what
Christopher is even hoping for his King
can't move his Knight is basically now
stuck uh anytime the night moves there's
going to be a night check the king can't
move because of F6 so it's time to play
A5
7 just 97. Jeffrey if 94 King E5 Maybe
our producer would have been so thrilled
and delighted to understand what could
what could white do after A5 just just
give me nothing I like a thing right no
absolutely nothing okay
um and by the way we see Knight to D3 I
guess that would just be a spike chat is
that the plan so he did not play A5 part
me he played Knight to D7 Knight to D3
Knight takes F6 you give a spy check on
F4 and then you resign yeah yes King is
seven that is a good point
check
and that's all she wrote check of Glory
yes
wow okay well again uh
oh never mind no Spike checks for you
Knight takes F6
94 B4 on the board okay three extra
pounds in the net ending it's time to
say that I would win this position
against the stockfish yeah
[Laughter]
uh-huh some of my viewers wrote to me
that these days we say stoppage yes I
would say after zero showing my great
understanding of what's going on in the
world of computers
um yeah okay it's too much three pawns
is too much we're gonna play C5 You're
Gonna Go Knight C6 we're gonna go A5 and
you're gonna go Knight E8 and I'm gonna
go King E7 and you're gonna run out of
checks yes because I will play F5 and
three pawns is way too many
so Jeffrey will win his first game and
for Christopher he lost his first game
inverted t-shirt
I was building up to something that I
don't know what it was night to B4 on
the board
yeah what do you have for us uh
Christian well it's all about these two
games uh the one between Alshon and Ray
Robson which by the way the last move G5
just played and Rey still has 10 minutes
so he's been blitzing out his last few
moves since this move Queen to H5 hasn't
spent a single second Knight to F4 by
the way D5 Knight to effort this was key
in the position and after Knight to H4
G5 nice move beautiful move came with
perfect timing I have to say this one is
starting to look almost over yeah it's
play on one goal you take here I take
your night but you're still getting
attacked yes on the king side and your
king is not running away the B4 is
coming if you go to F1 right opens up
the bishop uh that's going to deliver
more damage to your position this one is
looking over guys
I give you a check where do you go if
you go to H1 Rook to G8 is one way but
once again it's all about the opening of
this bishop Queen to E3 I take and
there's no more running for the queen to
defend the Knight on F3 this one is
pretty much over so
yeah big game for array and elshon is
sinking in the tournament right now one
and a half after this game out of eight
and uh well this is simply not his
tournament and Rey
seemances position as a solid 27 plus
level player and also keeps Pace with
Fabiano caruana yes indeed and again I'm
reminded of what happened it was five
draws for Rey went into the rest day and
this could be his third consecutive win
a hat-trick on from the rest day just
turning my attention oh but first before
turning my attention to Wesley so versus
darouch I think Wesley's taking over in
that game as well we have a guest with
Christian in studio
Megan a big victory for you you're
playing a uh streaking player ashrita
was coming out of three consecutive
victories how did you approach this game
um I think she definitely had a lot of
fighting Spirit during this game and I
think she wanted to win
um so she repeated the sebastianakov but
I found like a different line than Tata
flight so I think I was able to
maintain like a positional Advantage you
prepared this move Knight to D5 but it
seemed like she was ready for it because
she was blitzing out her moves as well
were you worried at any point especially
before taking this Pawn on D6
yeah I think when I played Bishop D2 I
don't think that's very common so I
wasn't sure if she was still in her prep
but I think it's pretty hard to
um have it anticipated I think what I
played so
but she did play the best moves all the
way up to this move B5
were you shocked about this development
B5 I was a little worried but I think if
I do it takes b
um
then she can sort of have a lot of
counter play and I didn't really like
that takes B6 yeah Queen takes B6 and E3
is coming as well did you consider
taking the B5 Pawn at any point
um I think I wanted to keep the position
sort of closed and not let her Knight
into the game absolutely and you play
this move B3 E3 F3
I want to ask you something did you spot
any uh moves at this point outside of
what she played with Quentin D6 uh I
thought she was maybe gonna do like
Queen E7 or like a knight H5 Knight F4
and try to
um did you spot this move
foreign
that's a nice one yeah yeah and now if
you take with the Queen the idea is that
Queen to have six counts with the temple
invades via B2 to F2 and this might
actually be quite worrisome for you
um she did not spot that she played very
quickly Queen to D6 and by the way
I think she played this movie in three
minutes four minutes that was quite
quick were you surprised by the way she
was playing her Pace um I think she
wanted to put a lot of pressure on the
clock so sometimes I get in time trouble
but I just try to keep steady Pace
during this game so and that you did
Bishop 32 going to B4
and how are you feeling at this point
after replay this move G3 you get King
to G2 coming in it feels like you
stabilized the position yeah I think
once I get G3 in um it's pretty
comfortable
um there's not too many threats I have
to worry about
um so I thought she might try to do like
a night sack really yeah so you
anticipated this move Knight to E4 yeah
but I I wasn't I thought it would be
okay like I could tuck my king on H1 and
um I don't think there's that many
mating chances yep and that's exactly
what you did then that's exactly what
you were supposed to do and after that
you converted nicely well at least until
until irina's game is over you are in
Seoul leadership position how do you
feel right now after eight months I
would never imagine being in this
position I think I'm just trying to play
good chess and
um just hanging in there and how's the
job going on are you doing your work
during the day or like at night yeah I'm
doing something
my parents are really helping me out
there at the shop right now that's
helping me so I really appreciate them
very nice very nice guys
our congratulations Megan and I thought
that the way you defended uh the peace
sacrifice is really nice I mean just
kept everything as you said tucked your
king away and it all went splendidly Yes
actually
I'm about to Megan and Wikipedia it's
written she runs two businesses she's a
business woman and how is it going I
mean let's say how does it fit with
chess's career I mean it was just
interesting to know more about it like
how modern lady manages all these things
all together it's not
it's not enough to be a grand master you
have to have two businesses how do you
manage your businesses I
it's pretty hard
I don't have that much free time
um but I try to do like everything and
is it if I'm out of business
um no I actually bought it myself but my
parents like really helped me out so
that I could be here there is an online
shop actually with many many nice
products and I was thinking to buy some
okay
what's your website
um shopsnipot.com sorry one more time
please uh shop snippet.com
yes yes snip it snippet yes snippet yes
and there are some nice nice things you
can buy not I didn't find anything
related with chess maybe it's time to do
something it's really popular what's
your most popular seller
um I think people really like pins and
yes there are some nice pieces okay
now they have to look yeah you have to
look now it's time to speak about it
thank you so much I mean it's really
encouraging for also young girl chess
players know you should try to find
different ways yes absolutely just
looking uh with Jennifer you again she's
on the outside looking in uh I'm I'm in
particular her game against Rochelle she
just uh well actually she's eating the
entire Pawn chain she dropped it The
Rook down on
C6 and hitting the base so you might
anticipate a move like Bishop D7
defending no said Rochelle I want to go
on the attack she went F5 F4 Rook to D6
and Bishop takes now here there was an
idea of maybe bishop takes F4 and uh
pardon me Bishop takes D4 Knight takes
F4 she went for the straight
takes takes but there goes the there
goes the whole Queen side slash Center
Rook takes H4 I think if I were in
Jennifer's shoes I would really
um like this capture very much my Rook
on H1 is doing nothing The Rook on F4
was maybe a little bit more scary I
could trade and I'm not worried about
Queen coming in I've got a knight on F1
let me just put this on the board pardon
me Rook takes Queen takes and of course
the desirable Rook d8 is not on tap I
could play a move like Queen G3 how
about that to try to get in a switch and
Zug yes our producers love it when I
speak German by the way
hey yeah and Jeffrey Jeffrey wins his
first game yes uh against Christopher
you uh on screen as you see their uh
signing of the score sheets uh Jennifer
boy what a roller coaster ride she's
been having uh but with a victory she
could potentially take second place
along with Arena should Arena draw and
when we left it while it was even it
seemed like the three result game where
are you Arena she was playing with white
she there she is again Sophie we left it
well after Bishop D3 I thought is when
we left it boy what's what's going on
Queen H3 okay here for sure we had this
moment
Bishop takes A3
4
Brook B8 Bishop C7
Brook C8 Queen D7 looks very attractive
for the moment until you see Bishop B5
C7 well Queen D1 no way I'm just gonna
win this Pawn back and no that's that's
just an even even game and a baby if I I
just hope that I didn't blunder any
quick attack against the F2 Pawn but uh
this game Arena's Advantage just
they spread it right away absolutely and
Alice Lee actually is winning her game
okay
right now okay so is it a completely
winning position wow so we left it we
thought that uh
Nazi was the one who was actually
pressing she did something wrong after
Bishop F5 she took I'm not sure about
the pressing she gave that pawn yes
early on in the opening she never
recovered well even in this position
she's
not doing okay I mean you could take the
pawn right yes
I mean you could give me a check but
it's I mean yeah so
you could take a pawn back I've got this
Pawn but maybe
I don't think I'm
I can't imagine I'm not doing okay uh
she didn't do that she took with the
bishop and this move might have
surprised her Knight D7 yes yes there it
is let's say if you take on the seven
Rook takes yes and then where do you go
no no no no no no no I take your knight
oh you think they're losing a piece
right now oh yes you lose the rug before
you're losing a piece
you're absolutely right and if you go
Rook B6 I have Bishop C8
that's cute that's a visual Rook the B6
Bishop to C8 this is just a good piece
right now wow
this idea A4 and then only Bishop C6
right and I'm sure you know this is the
cold shower you you play Bishop A7 you
can stop for just a moment you imagine
you don't see the move Knight D7
when you see Bishop A7 you think you're
winning yes because your next move is
going to be Rook takes and Rook down
you've got two connected past pawns you
start to think my opponent's going to
resign
when Alice played the move Knight D7 I
think that this was a really stunner
kind of a move because again Knight
takes D7 Bishop takes D7 and I am
losing a piece oh my word what a
turnaround that is Knight D7 and Alice
Alice comes in a point behind the
the the leaders today yes yes yes yes
yesterday yes she she thought she's died
for third place exactly so 97 but uh
Christian over to you and you have a
guest
Jeffrey finally you have cracked the
code after seven draws you finally get a
victory there was so much pressure on
you Anastasia took you as her pick to
win the tournament you felt the pressure
on your shoulders
well no but you know that you tell me
this I feel it a little bit
and how does uh that feel to finally get
a victory especially with the black
pieces
yeah I'm okay uh I guess it ruined my
chance at 13 draws but yeah it felt it
feels good to to break through for sure
especially
um it seemed like we're heading towards
the same direction in the game he went
for pretty safe approach with by the way
did you anticipate the fantasy variation
no no I don't think he's ever played it
but luckily I played it myself for white
so I knew uh some things and queen takes
D4 comedy by surprise because usually
um the movie is Knight D4 and yeah
there's some Sharp
uh continuation here after Knight F6
I think it's like
um E5 Knight G4
E6 yeah Bishop B6 Bishop C4 and I think
it's a drop so he probably wanted to get
a game with Queen D4 but
there I thought
still seemed reasonable yeah Bishop B6
but wasn't it a bit strange that he
played this move F3 and was still
spending some time up to this point yeah
I wasn't sure what what exactly
if whether he's recalling or he's sort
of
bluffing a little bit like maybe he has
some really nice ideas and wants to
pretend like he doesn't know the
position so yeah I just
thought okay Bishop B6 just to get out
of his prep because I knew Bishop V6 for
sure cannot be
uh like a main move and then yeah here I
think it's just equal so 97 was maybe a
clever
um way just to get 96 with a tempo and I
think the key in the position is to
control the E5 Square so it made a lot
of sense to me
um
so yeah Bishop D6 I think he wanted to
force this
end game that we got where he at least
jumps Knight F5 do you feel like he was
trying to pull the brakes at this point
already yeah I think so because
otherwise if I I mean if I get my
blockade on E5 it's very pleasant so
Knight F5 it seemed correct
and I think the critical moment uh if we
just keep going down
yeah rookie [ __ ] was a good I think it's
a good try to fight for the atrial
but the key I think is uh okay H4 is
fine and by the way it does seem like
right now the engines are recommending
black as the favorite yeah yeah I I
slightly prefer black but I think his
main mistake was trading Rooks why do
you prefer black because it does look
like okay he has the bishop he has more
space on the king side why do you prefer
I think it's due to my really nice
Knight on E5 and the pawn on F5 is
overextended a little bit so I can sort
of Target that in the future so the pawn
uh our launch maybe is working against
him on the king side yeah
H6 Knight to E4 and U.S 96 but here I
thought F6 immediately was maybe a
better solution if you wanted to play F6
uh because yeah now he gets goes Rook H6
and I don't think I can take and the key
is actually on H6 or yeah I don't think
I can take on H6
um because yeah he will get H7 a G5 so
rookies H1 H7 and Knight to G5 well at
least it wasn't clear how how I win the
pawn so yeah the point is actually very
important that if I take on D1 after F6
he can take with the bishop yeah instead
of G6
he takes with the bishop to avoid the to
avoid the uh yeah so now if you take
take on G7 that's winning and if you go
well if you cannot go to six yeah so
then yeah but in general FG should be
just dropped closer yeah it should be
dropped got it so this was the way for
him to probably put the brakes
um completely at this point because yeah
now I Think It's Tricky for him right
and he played this move C4 this
completely shocked us yeah
uh I was wondering what is his idea and
then I think I figured it out he was
maybe for whatever reason assuming that
I would throw in Rook H2
because it looks nice and then at least
here he has rookie one okay and maybe
now I can't take the pawn because if
they take a knight C5 yeah
then the rule comes to you at least yeah
here he has play so I don't know what it
what it was exactly but he maybe forgot
I could just take uh immediately
immediately with the rook and then the
Rook comes to E8 perhaps this is what he
missed yeah but I think I mean you you
stopped calculating though if you see
this I mean I have more uh
like I have other options I can play
Knight B6 as well
here yeah so for sure I I think he just
uh
yeah it's hard to say maybe you just
forgot I could take immediately
Wesley uh Wesley
congratulations a big victory for you uh
how are you feeling about your chances
with Fabiano right now surging through
the rankings Rey also winning game after
game what do you need to do to win this
event yeah Fabian Ray I I think they're
just playing amazingly if they continue
there's not much I can do so
yeah I have a very tough schedule coming
up so I'll just do my best
guys yeah quick question for you Jeffrey
first of all our congratulations of
course and as a Karo Khan player uh I
had some awkward experiences against the
fantasy variation and you chose a
defense Queen B6 that I've never used
I've used G6 in my practice uh G6 I've
taken taken E5 Knight F3 and Bishop E6
again these are ways I've met the
fantasy variation you chose Queen B6 how
did you come up with this I mean it's
it's an unusual approach for me how did
you come up with Queen B6 yeah it was
actually a long time ago I think when I
first picked up the caracon back in 2012
I want to say this is the line my coach
uh taught me so I actually I sort of
kept it I mean I I dabbled with other
moves like you said D4 E5 and and G6 I
played for both of colors but I felt
like yeah Queen B6
I don't know it gave me like most of the
variations seem to be uh
quite playable so yeah
good who was the coach who recommended
Queen B6
[Laughter]
his name is Gabor he's from Hungary very
very nice Queen B6 now I'm gonna have to
go research it but congratulations
Jeffrey thank you yeah I have a question
to Jeffrey I mean I think he's a
professional chess player right now and
I was wondering what are the advantages
to be a professional chess players these
days or advantages and disadvantages if
you have some ideas
yeah well there are definitely a lot of
advantages and disadvantages for me
personally I think I I value the online
opportunities a lot nowadays so you
don't necessarily have to just travel 24
7 essentially and make a living now with
the online tournaments it's very very
flexible so I'm happy about that
and disadvantages if you have any
just to know
what are the downsides affecting D5
yeah
they're they're let's just let's just
say uh there are some negative things
about being a chess player but good
price fund I mean you still have a good
price money these are I think advantages
right that is true yes okay thank you so
much and all the best of luck absolutely
um now that uh we've got our predictions
on the board uh well I was about to say
let's take a look at the game of Lavon
but let's take a look at the results uh
thus far you have only one decisive game
as you could see uh Krishna for you lost
against Jeffrey and then we have also
two drawers Alexander Linderman and made
the draw with linear domindus as well as
a Wonderland with Sam Shanklin alrighty
and uh again because we saw that
wonderful uh snippet there of uh
predictions I want to say uh Lavon
I mean VAR and I you know Brotherhood
and everything uh what when for when for
Lavon and he's enjoying this extra Pawn
really he's been enjoying it out of the
opening uh but this last move uh C5 C4 I
think came in a very timely fashion as
Hans is looking to get in Bishop Shack
when the pawn is hanging so I do have F5
I do have Rook Shack but I think this
move C4
um you don't like oh my gosh yeah well
I I I'm I'm afraid that lavon's
Advantage is not enough uh that just the
way I I'm I'm reading this uh maybe he
missed timed the move F4 Rook B7 I
thought he was uh doing pretty good up
to this moment
but um like what to play now yes I mean
if Knight moves you take on a four or
what
yeah that okay just a second I Rook the
B7 King to E6 was played because
otherwise I was I was taking yes and
Lavon played F4 so I'm sure he
anticipated C4 what am I missing
Christian I I feel like uh Lebron was
better before
no no you're not missing anything
actually he wasn't much better he was
not at any point no no Hans kept it
quite close Okay
corrected yeah yeah and right now he's
just more or less equal yeah of course
white still to be preferred you take on
F5 take only seven take on D3 and maybe
go something like Rook to E3 and say
that if you want to defend the pawn on
D3 I have Rook F3 ideas but normally
this should end in a draw yeah Bishops
of opposite colors something like Bishop
F3 maybe even Bishop B5 yeah things of
that nature well yeah I would probably
well yeah okay so a draw is a likelihood
here let's jump to the game of Ray
Robson uh for a moment because it's it's
messy well Kevin
um
there there are Pawn structures
and then there are other kinds of pond
structures so what we have here is
two sets of double Parts
I'm sorry yes
just to interrupt you I think Jennifer
you is just about to win her game
Jennifer is about the way looking at
that I think Rey is just about to oh
he's well also yes yes yes yes yeah this
last move Rook G8 with the threat of
Rook G1 is but this one will actually
hang on for a while right all right if
you say so maybe Jennifer minutes but
Jennifer is just like she's promoting
it's already over in fact okay well
timed we weren't fast enough
even and uh this was where we saw this
Rook takes H4 and I was saying that
Jennifer will be delighted by that trade
of Rook she did play Queen G3 as well uh
Queen H1 Knight F1 and
Jennifer
opened up the G file and pushed her Pawn
home well done as again she's having
this incredibly topsy-turvy event she
won the U.S Women's Championship with an
incredible score
something like this so we know that she
can go on these winning streaks but
she's mixed it with a couple of losses
as well at the moment she's a half a
point behind Megan uh lee an arena Crush
let's just confirm yes we're about to
confirm a drawing here it is
soon yeah the professional approach
would be to move the Kings backwards and
forwards between G7 and f8 and that way
you know you can make sure by the way in
the women's section we only have two
results but both of them are victories
for the player with the white pieces
Alice Lee is she going to yes she won
the piece just as we saw it back here
after Knight D7
for Nazi what a shock yes again because
if you don't see the move Knight D7 you
think you're playing Bishop B7 and
winning yes instead uh Alice she has one
Pawn for the piece okay we have of
course two connected passports but I'm
not sure it's enough right but still
some chances yeah well usually the the
long range pieces rook and Bishop most
especially deal effectively with passers
like you can go A5 I'll take this Pawn
I'll put my Bishop back on e4 I'll go
check and
I just need one pass Pawn
uh so Alice looks like she's in pole
position back over to you Christian
let's take a look at what's happening in
sabino's game maybe
I haven't seen Sabina versus begum and
quite some well right it looks good for
Sabino but right now and she only has a
few seconds left on her clock maybe we
can see her clock and her reactions uh
because there's some checkmating threats
in the position
and it's a bit awkward to deal with that
after this movie won beg him yeah for
Sabina with the white pieces with white
well wait a minute but I'm seeing some
check mating patterns for for her
opponent as well right for begging yes
yes and she did play the move King to F3
which I think was the right movie
sidestepping this very a challenging
move Rook F1 was going to win the game
B3 on Rook a three how do you
ah okay so now you take on G7 okay that
makes sense
perhaps even after Rook to E2 Rook to A3
things of that nature right I understand
what you're saying uh or does it make
any any sense I'm just looking to take
this phone and go back how about how
about rookie to first rookie one yeah
rookie one so I'm trying to trick you
into uh something of this name oh
there's the maid yeah yeah very nice
very nice yes sir yes but again I'm just
asking for a lot of cooperation for
really really good friends uh so yeah
maybe rookie one idea also is if you
drop back with the
bishopics
you're focused on Checkmate yes I'm
looking for pieces so perhaps the best
is to just take on G7 off the rookie one
after Rook E1 just take on G7 maybe the
best is just to take yes I understand
you completely Rook B1 King F3 and
rookie
on G7
oh
yeah this is not an easy one and they
still have a few moves to go until the
time control exactly and we have a
result we do yes
made the draw are they are repeating yes
with Khan's name on the game is about to
finish in a
drawing and it looked like that so let's
maybe
see the last seconds
does the right thing he stops the clock
and he tells the Arbiter I am going to
make this move I commit myself to making
this move but I'm I'll say that this is
a three move repetition yes and you know
how they check so quickly I I learned
the the procedure yes the trick is that
Leonard has uh opened or he's doing the
duty boards and
um he shows he makes some sign to the
Arbiters yes yes it's like three times
repetition so
this is
and uh I also uh getting uh news that
Ray Robson yes he was on the verge of
precipice of Victory and he got it he
won he won this game wow and a really
key that Victory really keeps the
pressure on
to Abby
we have a guest in studio over to you
Christian we do have indeed Jennifer you
with us right now uh Jennifer yesterday
a tough loss but immediately bounced
back and you played a very good friend
of yours Rochelle Wu today is that a
Bittersweet uh victory for you
yeah I mean I feel like Russell is like
my little sister but you know kind of
tournaments we get used to playing
against each other like we always play
against Juniors and I actually always do
really bad against her I always play
like my worst game of my life against
her so I'm glad I didn't lose this game
um but yeah let's discuss uh today's
game because it was actually quite tense
out of the opening
um
I'm just gonna go E6 first
um but wait wait she told you that she's
going to play this against you yesterday
no after the round I was like I was like
oh I wasn't expecting 86 and she said
she played this yesterday against Alice
and I saw like a position but I thought
it was a different move order
um I was just yeah so I haven't played
this that's why
um and I looked at this years ago for
black so I didn't really remember I just
remember C5
um was like something I was looking at
but
I think this is normal but I
um just trying to create uh come up with
a plan because this part was like really
tricky here and
it might not have done I think C5 ideas
yeah so Knight takes C5
um I looked at this for a while and I
think I really liked the position after
something like 95 or even takes on e4 oh
Knight to E5 yeah I was the deciding
between them like if she was gonna play
this um I just saw that like I was happy
with this continuation
um because you're gonna get to take here
maybe and take on C6 yeah
you get the Palm back and I think you
know I'm kind of active even though I'm
not completely developed on the king
side
Bishop D3 maybe Castle you definitely
gain some speed and she decided to go
Knight C3 Queen takes C3 and then she
was looking to play E5 which makes a lot
of sense in this type of structures
how would you did you assess the
position at this point
or I was really happy
for
um because I think if she kept it like
kind of tense in the center there play
Queen E7
um or queen E7 I think is better
um it's just you know it is really
complicated I don't know maybe what the
I don't know what the objective
evaluation is it's like around okay
not feel like it was plus one
um but it's just the thing is I guess
it's hard for her to come up with a plan
because she if she doesn't push on e4
it's like it's not clear what to do and
I just developed but also I don't know
exactly how I would continue like maybe
just be sure because at least you have a
couple of yeah I've a few moves and then
they have to come up with a plan and
then that's like the thing that's so
tricky about this is I have this nice
space Advantage but it's like what do I
do with that absolutely and uh
she played E4 and you said that you were
happy after this one
is
I just felt like I'm after especially
after she moved the night from D7 I just
felt like I
it's very easy for me to play here now
which wasn't the case and she kept on E5
like maybe I was objectively better but
here I just you know put my Rook to the
open file and just kind of um develop
maybe I'll move the night I was thinking
moving and I come to E2 to G3 but and it
doesn't seem like she has a lot of
counter plays yes
and this is what happened she was trying
to find some counter play of course with
F4
yeah don't think there's quite words at
this point it seems like you're just
simply breaking through and actually the
king in the center is pretty safe for
you yeah
Jennifer uh a big game for you A big
bounce back a victory how do you feel
about your chances going in the last
five rounds
the thing is like the last few days have
been
um like the last few games especially
since like the rest day were not that
great
um but I was also like I had kind of
struggling because I was um I had a lot
of academic stuff going on so I like I
think it's pretty obvious from my
openings I was there was not that much
prep
um so I'm honestly I felt like like
against Alice I was like really happy
just didn't lose that game
um because you know I was running like
three hours of sleep and turning the
paper right before right before the game
started so um now I'm just you know
trying to because I think I got like
some things out of the way
um I can really like put my mind more on
this tournament
um because it's just like weird juggling
everything but you know
I mean it's pretty good situation to be
and I think you might as high for a
second I don't really know I think so
yeah yeah
um I think Megan won and Megan won so
she's uh at she's the leader probably
okay in the last five okay yeah I mean
it's like a good spot to be like I was
kind of discouraged yesterday I was like
I don't know what I'm doing and the way
I played was just really bad I couldn't
like I just wasted all my time beginning
to but you know I mean there's still
half the tournament love which is weird
but it's a long tournament still plenty
of rounds to go we'll let you get uh
some rest more than three hours of sleep
hopefully we'll see you tomorrow uh
Jennifer quick question for you because
I saw a position and I was kind of
shocked for a moment that like you had
allowed this possibility I've got this
position after move 14 E3 you just
played the move E3 and I just flashed uh
to this moment and I saw that Rochelle
had an opportunity for Knight D7 take C5
what was your intention to play if she
is captured um Planet Fitness yeah oh
okay so I was kind of juggling between
Knight takes E4 and 95 but
um I thought regardless I could just get
the pawn back first like and then I felt
comfortable especially 95 actually liked
a lot
okay I I mean so like you you didn't
blunder the pawn or anything like that
and only noticed it later because at the
moment I mean it was like wow if you can
grab that C5 Pawn for free that's a
different my all together all together
yeah so that's why I thought like 94 was
a really good move by her because
um she has to take advantage of like
this temporary weakness here exactly
Jennifer uh you're on a roller coaster
ride uh
yeah keep right riding the roller
coaster go girl
congratulations yes great result today
well done all right uh by the way the
results are coming in hot and heavy I
think all of the results in the open
exactly as the last game uh Sam
Sauvignon held on uh difficult position
against Fabi yes and Fabiano Corona
still is on he's on the first place but
look at this I mean rare Oaks and who
won his game he's just a half a point
behind so the distance is is different
right now it's only half a point and
then we have linear Domingo so Jeff is
wrong
um
and also I wonder all of them they share
third place there's four and a half
points coming in today's and the latest
results too by the way and the latest
results we have a few games so still two
games oh two games yes so Jennifer you
uh won her game arena crash made the
draw Megan Lee uh won against Rita
um so that's it right so we have four
other games are still on the way I think
in now yes again seriously but still
yes uh nice and uh Christian with our
number two player in the tournament it's
Wayne after win after win ready for you
you must be ecstatic also you cross 2700
for the first time in your career how do
you feel right now and which one is more
important being only half a point behind
the leader and getting those victories
or crossing 2700.
um yeah actually they're similarly
important I think around 2014 I decided
that okay maybe I'll never achieve my
full potential but I still had three
kind of long-term goals I wanted to
achieve in my career one was to meddle
at an Olympiad which back then seemed
like it would be very difficult even
though we had a strong team and very
good team chemistry our team was not one
of the very top teams obviously I was
fortunate to be on the 2016-2018 teams
which did medal when our teams were
super strong so that was accomplished
and the other two were to reach 2 700
and to win U.S championships so I'm very
happy I'm 2700 at least in library right
now but uh yeah seems like U.S
Championship is obviously these days is
the hardest one to uh to achieve
absolutely but you're definitely In
Contention to potentially reach your
final goal
what's going to come after that yeah you
win it what's going to come after that
oh yeah I've been thinking a little bit
like what do I really want to do I guess
I would like to get into some of these
like Elite events so obviously I need to
raise my rating up to probably at least
like 27 30 to have some chance to get
invited some of the very highest events
and I don't know it would just be nice
to play in some super tournaments I
haven't really had that opportunity I
think American cup I got to play with
some of the really top players and that
was great for me so I would like to do
that on a more regular basis well the
climb never stops so let's take a look
at today's game you guys started off
with uh the Berlin and actually Yasser
was telling us a story about his
roommate Alexander shabalov speaking
with elshon and telling him hey just go
play the Berlin make a draw
he was trying to make a Droid suit like
but you were still keeping the tension
in the position were you harboring hopes
of potentially winning this one I mean I
don't think he was trying to make a job
he want to make a drive probably like
Castle on move four play rookie why
didn't get a symmetrical position yes I
mean the line he played is a line with
Bishop takes C6 Knight bd2 is one of the
most critical lines I used to play this
basically every game with white against
the Berlin
um Sam Shanklin actually played it in
round one of this tournament against me
so no I thought it would just be a game
here but I didn't really like the way I
played it I mean when he started to play
A4 which was I didn't expect A4 at all
um yeah also here by the way after
Knight C5 Knight takes E5 I don't know
objectively but it looked quite
interesting F takes E5 Queen H5 king f8
queen takes E5 96 I thought long Castle
and I give Queen F6 Queen A5 he keeps
the Queens on and he'll try to play like
Rook F1 F4 and just push his pawns and
okay I suspected it wasn't that
objectively but it still looked quite
difficult to play for exactly yeah yeah
yeah your king is still unsafe uh
definitely an interesting option but he
decided to shy away from that
and uh yeah here this A4 and I spent a
really long time on Bishop A6
um yeah he wants to just play A5 but the
other thing is let's say if I castle at
any moment he's ready to play D4 and
then if I take take he has at least
Knight takes and queen C4 check so it
was possible that maybe I should have
castled early and just simplified maybe
this is still around equal but yeah I
played this move Bishop A6 and
kind of a weird move and I wasn't really
sure what's going on so the point is not
just pressuring D3 but I'm also covering
C4 so now I'm prepared to Castle in the
future and then when he plays D4 uh yeah
Castle's short and when he plays D4 and
we do the same line I'll cover C4 so
yeah he played B4 which I expected okay
Rook d8 B5 and now maybe if you go
Castle the same thing after a B5 right
B5 and then D4 yeah and it's even better
yeah so Rook d8 B5 Bishop B7
um Queen B3 to protect uh B5 and prepare
A5 and here I play Queen F7 and here I
don't think G3 was the best I thought he
should just play A5 I thought G3 was too
slow so he must have been uh worried
about Knight F4 which is probably what I
was going to play take take I thought a
b a b Rook A7 Rook B8 but I mean he can
never be worse and I wasn't sure if he's
actually just like clearly better if
it's around equal yeah he could play C4
let's say C4 rook d8 and Knight D5
Knight E6 and I didn't really see how
he's breaking through and I thought
maybe like very slowly I can unwind
because yeah I mean my Bishop is stuck
but he has no way to pressure it as far
as I saw so he can try to slowly maybe
play on the king side but I thought
maybe I'm holding this but this was what
I was most concerned about in G3 G3
allowed A5 after which I felt much
better absolutely and the engine was
recommending your position especially
once you manage to play B5 yeah B5 was
stabilized then
and yeah I think okay next very
interesting moment would have to D4
Queen H5 D5 Knight F4 very uh unexpected
complications and here I think he just
blundered I was expecting okay the
engine shows GF but that looks worse for
white I was expecting uh maybe Knight
three to H4
yeah and here yeah I was considering
this line G5 Knight G2 and I have Knight
H3 but after King H1 Queen F3 I thought
if he just protects like Rooker D2 I can
open my Bishop at any moment with B4 but
I wasn't sure I mean it's a very very
weird position okay apparently I have
Bishop D3 threat which I didn't notice
but yeah very weird so after G5 Knight
G2 one yeah move 26. one option I was
thinking about was Queen E2
um and then if he takes I take with
check and take on C3 and support it with
B4
um and if he doesn't take then I at
least have Perpetual like Knight H3 King
and Shawn Knight F2 King G1 I H3 King H1
and then I wasn't sure actually if I
should play for more yeah because he has
compensation I mean G5 is was quite
weakening so this still would have been
very unclear I think we both had low
time but I think Knight five H4 he
started kind of shaking yeah you started
kind of like shaking his head a little
bit Yeah and obviously G5 was logical
move and I I realized it just blundered
it I guess and after that you uh
converted swiftly Ray congratulations a
hat trick for you when's the last time
you scored a hat-trick
oh I'm I'm not sure I think in most wins
I had against strong opposition was in
one of the Fall Classics I think 2019
fall classic
um I believe I beat five 26 hundreds in
a row so that was one of my best results
yeah that's impressive for sure guys
yeah well first of all you came in Ray
with a 28-31 performance rating today's
result will certainly add to that uh
what happened between the five draws
rest day and three wins because if we
can put it in a can
and market and sell it uh we've got a
million dollar idea
what happened you're winning on through
on the trot
I really don't think I'm playing like
much better or anything I think I'm
playing at a similar level as I have
been the whole tournaments just in the
first four rounds I played you know like
Sam Shanklin and a bunch of like 2750s
and I had three blacks and one white
um and then I had white against Darius
in round five uh where I was pressing I
had very good chances to win that game
but I missed my chance and he defended
well so that was the first half and then
I think I just kept playing pretty well
in the second half and I think my
punches just have given me more chances
um it's as simple as that well
congratulations Ray and may all your
goals uh come true exactly yes great
goals great motivation well done well
done uh keep it up indeed and by the way
the results are coming hot and Furious I
do believe all of the open uh results
have happened and we do have two games
going on uh with uh two games left in
the ladies six Pardon Me Five results
and also we know that Alice live won her
game against Nazi by kids remember yeah
Jennifer we just interviewed uh two
games remaining in uh Sabina begin or
ongoing Tata and Talia are also ongoing
and again I just wanted to say yeah that
that's exactly what did in fact happened
I wanted to be sure that Bobby drew his
game because he was nursing an extra
Bond but I just didn't see how three
versus two but I just didn't see how he
was going to get anything out of that
extra Pawn in it yes
and our friend he has
we have Wesley so in the studio Wesley
difficult game for you yesterday and
even today you were under some pressure
how do you feel yeah I'm not sure yeah
I'm not exactly sure why what I'm doing
here in this interview it seems like
they just want to ask you and person
questions when you're done
we want to torture you yes exactly
uh how my day goes during all the U.S
championships I played so far it's uh it
was a difficult game indeed
yes yeah actually I thought it was very
complicated but oh can't turn on the
engine because sure you want to see how
bad like I think if the H3 maybe G3 is
slightly better for white yeah I could
be wrong
okay it's just all equal yeah it's so
crazy how the computer evaluates
position these days because black has a
double pawn and my king side is solid
but then the computer gives all zero so
it fits insane like humanly I think
everyone would take white but
anyway after H3 Knight F4 very
interesting I didn't expect that he
would go all in with G5 G3 G4 he is
gaining some momentum I do one yeah
definitely at all worried at this point
how did you assess it did you feel like
you were worse better neutral I mean of
course I wanted to play for a win with
white yeah so I mean
that's exactly my downfall instrument
like if you want to try to play for a
win but then you start risking and then
you make then you start losing the
threat and the players are very strong
and they but I thought I thought today I
was wasn't that badly off that's why I'm
curious to see what the engine thought
because instead of Knight G1 no I think
that was the best move now you want the
best I think you think that Force also
equally yes
um but maybe not that easy yeah I mean
you have to go something like Knight D4
but not what you were calculating in 94
button even Rook E1 G6
E5 Knight D2
yeah it should be equal
[Music]
um
for for black right yeah it depends what
they well I mean humanly again if equal
but the computer has other ideas yeah
yeah I didn't expect this G5 G4 it's
very strong Darius is playing very well
in this tournament is also playing very
confidently but again I didn't think I
was that worth so we need it I think
there was one moment uh somewhere around
this point when you got your Rook to H1
instead of Rook H7 Queen to G4 seems to
have been a very testing option ah we
bought Memphis
four ideas
take and queen takes F3 oh yeah without
a limited because we I think we have
different mind but with the queen of H5
which is slightly different because it's
still not over by the way
but it just remains complicated the game
remains complicated I didn't think if I
take E4 after Queen G4 yeah I mean I
think white can hold probably but yes if
you go back after Queen G4 King E1
there's ideas of D5 as well
seems like he's keeping some pressure in
the position can you go back on move 23
how should I look at oh after H5 on mode
22 sure
yeah I guess I thought I had some
something here but I guess it it never
works like okay I mean black
why does some ideas but I don't think
they ever work like after Rook H1 I
think black only has one way to play Oh
but that computer give them into it
let a B5 okay E5 is not a human movie H4
you're not even looking at that side
Knight F3 Queen G4 check King G2 Knight
H5
yeah and it never works on so yeah 4K H4
probably Knight F4 and queen takes H4
yeah neither fourth so after Rook H1
yeah very interesting game I like okay
very interesting game absolutely I mean
if we make the mistake he could also
lose H2 Knight F1 or H4 yeah I guess
it's all just equal exactly yeah nothing
happened after that you guys kept it
quite uh quite tense but pretty neutral
yeah I mean queen G8 King G8 so it is
Queen H6 Queen Jade King G8
excuse me what like here Queen takes
King takes okay then King D2 and so
forth yes oh yeah I mean play a few
moves Wesley still a lot of games to go
five rounds to go how do you turn this
tournament around
wait for next year
you're not harboring any uh hopes or uh
I mean I'm waiting for a victory to five
if like 33 and a half points ahead of me
how can I ever hope for a victory but
the good thing are the prices of the US
Championship have increased compared to
because it's been the same I think for
the last five six years and I just not
if the fear it in grief but I'd like to
thank Rex and Genie very much of course
for after about an inflation somehow oh
yeah here
we're starting to talk political here
considering the November elections and
it's the first year that I can vote so
there you go we have the battle
inflation somehow and Free Speech yeah
oh my goodness but um
yeah obviously things didn't start the
way I wanted it to think uh their number
of reasons um
but I think also in between this
tournament and the chess 960 there is
only a space of 12 Days really and I
just didn't pay enough serious attention
to this tournament I didn't have much
time to prepare I play some online
tournaments played like a lot of Blitz
Games and it just
I knew this tournament was going to be
hard I think the U.S Championship is
probably the hardest tournament I play
every single year because uh everyone is
it huh why is it the hardest in your
opinion uh because because you play a
lot of elite events right against 27 50
plus yeah
it's hard I mean this is my eighth
year's championship I believe or seven I
think eight but it's basically a mixture
of top players like Fabi and then you
have all the young up and coming guys
the kids
then you have a very experienced very
strong players you know like used to be
a scorpion but he doesn't play anymore
on his truck but gather comskey but now
you have like elshon Harry Robson uh
Sam Fabian I mean these guys are low
rated than us but on a very good day on
a good day they couldn't beat anybody in
the world and basically in order not to
lose his rating you have to score at
least plus three or plus four
for guys like me and right now I'm on
minus one so I'm obviously losing a
bunch and uh everyone is well prepared
here I think American players in general
are very booked up in comparison to
Asian players or other different players
and
they all play for a win I mean I also
want to play for a win myself but then
can backfire
easily so
and if you look at the history I
basically lose an average of like 12
breaking points the U.S championship
year after year so I think live on it I
have made our annual rating uh
contribution awesome Wesley thank you
very much uh for all these insights
we'll see you tomorrow yeah be back
tomorrow for more torture
thank you very welcome thank you Wesley
we look forward to the torture yes
indeed we have two ladies uh games
remaining and uh I think they're gonna
we're gonna see more decisive games
we've already got three decisive games
but I think Sabina is winning and tatv
is facing a puzzle Rush tactic at the
moment the last move yes the last move
uh puzzle Rush will tell you
yes uh Rook A8 if you dare capture this
Pawn uh I think this tactic is good for
the survival tactics in puzzle rush I
think this is worth two points you get
two uh examples of these Rook sacrifices
and uh checkmates the night covers the
Escape squares
are you ready yes this is it here it
comes ready the rook and Knight
wow wow but uh back to you Christian
Alice uh a big victory for you after
yesterday disappointing game against
Rochelle how did you combat
psychologically for from that loss yeah
I mean so of course yesterday was sort
of tough I got a bad opening and then
she was able to get a good position and
after that I was able to equalize but
the queen end game she sort of grinded
me down
um so today I was just trying not to
lose because like you know if you lose
you just don't want to have back-to-back
losses
um so yeah I just tried to play a solid
c as possible
um that's a very experienced strategy in
general
people your age they want to come back
immediately right they're like I want to
play some Sicilian some crazy Sicilians
gambits and just to get a try to get a
win yeah I mean today's my birthday so I
actually did it
yes happy birthday I just didn't want to
lose so like um I played E4 E5 and I
actually haven't played this before
um and then he played Knight C3 which I
wasn't expecting since I think usually
in the past she's done Knight F3
um
yeah he went for this one so I hadn't
really reviewed this line before the
game so I sort of knew what to do but
um I also like didn't so later on Knight
C6 Queen E3 Bishop B4 Castle I think
this is all wrong good
um you can also take with a rook at this
point which Anastasia was showing take
with the rook and then you cannot take
back because if I take C4 yeah but
taking with the Knight is also fine yeah
I think the line after effects before
that I looked at before was like Brook
takes before
um oh no after uh Rick takes E4 the
previous move I think Bishop F4 was what
it was and I actually didn't remember
what to do here
um it seems like Queen F6 might be the
best move and then I know that there
were some really crazy lines here but
I'm glad that she didn't go for them and
she did Bishop takes B4 after that uh
yeah I worked it before and I take
before both possible but I thought that
she got A3 either way so it'd be the
same position uh yeah so Ricky ate and
and then she played this move Queen to
G5 offering the queen trade uh were you
surprised by this decision yeah I
definitely wasn't expecting it because I
thought any Queen trade would be good
for me but
not sure what to do because I was
worried that like she might do queen
takes up six at some point uh which
would be slightly annoying like not
necessarily a queen text F6 is their
idea right now but I thought like if she
you go Bishop she respects and like
Queen takes f63 takes F6 and yeah H5 it
doesn't really look that um amazing as
though like I'm still slightly better
she might eventually get like that five
square Knight H4 Bishop F5
um yeah so so you didn't want to see
your Pawn structure shatter yeah I mean
I was mostly considering a 95 after this
but then I thought like Queen takes F6 G
takes F6 Knight D4 and I guess and
Knight takes D3 check is good here
um but I didn't really like this for
some reason
um and it makes a lot of sense I mean
Rook G3 is coming this night is pretty
powerful in the center the material is
quite limited so it's not easy yeah so I
decided to do queen takes G5 I wasn't
sure how good of a decision this was in
the game since like it opened up the H
file so yeah I was expecting her to yeah
I didn't expect Bishop B2 actually
because it allows me to do Knight D7 and
then I wanted to Knight f8 next which
well not necessarily right over here but
if she ever like does Rook H1 then
Knight f8 will just defend everything so
after C4
um yeah I think this was all good things
are simplified a little bit and then
here uh yeah I played Bishop F5 so I was
getting a bit low on time here and I
still had like 12 more moves 13 more
moves to make
um and a snoop like after Bishop F5
Knight takes B7 uh Rook C8 King D2 Rook
C2 King E3 rectus V2 rectus A6 I wasn't
sure what to do here but like I saw
maybe I could try like Rook B3 and 94.
00 position is simplified yeah so you're
not risking much yeah uh but she played
Bishop takes B7 which I was hoping
um because now I can play Knight D7 and
she probably missed this move because
like if you aren't looking like
sometimes these background night moves
are hard to see
um and also like Knight takes C7 Bishop
takes D7 Rook B4 then I have A5 and then
after she moved to work uh then the rook
and the bishop are independently but to
win an exchange if you go here Bishop C8
if you go Rook B3 Bishop C6 yeah very
nice everything works out uh fine for
you and after that you went on and
converted a nice Advantage Alice
congratulations you're still in the
chasing pack for the championship we'll
let you rest then we'll see you tomorrow
thank you congratulations on your
birthday Alice 13 years young wonderful
wonderful wonderful and uh
actually Alice Ellis this show which
Alice is running I mean how did actually
come out with this idea and actually
is it in your plan to become a
commentator one day
I don't know I mean I've done some
commentating with chess kid in the past
so I do have some experience I think for
now I'm just focusing on playing good
chess
good for you yes
go and win all the titles you can and
then come back and be a commentator
that's the way it works good luck Alice
uh well done well done uh two remaining
games and again we have these decisive
results three decisive results and I
think we're gonna see two more as I'm
just looking at the game between tatev I
believe and tell you uh Italian started
with a lot of draws then she had this uh
tough loss I believe to Arena but now
everything's going away and if I've got
the correct position on the board remove
B3 once again threatens that whole Rook
take C2 Rook takes C1 and Rook takes A2
patterns and if you play a move like A3
well I can reinforce a new threat now
Rook takes A3 check
oh oh yeah that's exactly
yeah that's exactly the way I was
feeling the uh oh and so this looks very
very good for Talia and for some reason
um begum in a position where I thought
it was really double-edged she ended up
playing it very very defensively uh she
she ended up recapturing on G7 with a
knight the Knight got pinned she ended
up having a rook on G8 and now it's all
Sabina Sabina has just played this move
a
D4 to D5 menacing the bishop coming to
uh D4 capturing on F6 and that's all she
wrote you you just you can't play this
and I think begum didn't realize that
her her passive setup is no Fortress
because it's just not a good position
for her whatsoever and I think we're
going to see two more victories yes it
looks like that
sure and uh we'll be back to see if that
prediction is true we'll see on the
other side of the break
[Music]
as part of the World Chess Hall of Fame
lecture series author and international
Master John Donaldson will be doing a
live presentation on the 1972 Fisher
spasky match examining their early lives
and careers leading up to their classic
match you can join John live on October
18th at the World Chess Hall of Fame or
watch the live stream on the World Chess
Hall of Fame YouTube channel that's
October 18th John Donaldson live more
information at stlouisjessclub.org
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
welcome back to round eight of us chess
championships we have standings so for
open section bandiano caruana leads with
six points magnificent result no
question about it only half a point
behind him will have rare options on the
second place also magnificent results no
question about it as well so and look at
this one point distance
four and a half points a few players
have a linear Domingos Jeff Darius sam7
as well as a Wonderland all of them four
and a half points one point behind uh
Ray Robinson wow and in the ladies we
have some results with two games
remaining Anastasia yes two games are
still on the way 30 was playing against
Thailand as well as Sabina fighting
against begging but we have a few
decisive gifts actually three of them
Jennifer you won her game against her
shelvu and jumped on the second position
right now Nazi lost against ellisley and
then we have also one decisive result
against Megan Lee against Theresa
Sharita coming into today's game with a
nice winning streak that Megan Lee put a
stop to that winning to take clear first
at this moment Sabina seems to be
putting together her best game at the
tournament as she has a winning position
in my view against begum last move was
D5 and check this out
Sabina is just ready to play Bishop D4
pouncing on this diagonal begum had to
stop that she did that with Rook D1 no
Bishop to D4 how can you get this bishop
into the game well just found a really
really nice idea she's going to play
Bishop to f8 when you take the bishop I
have a Checkmate on the seventh rank
it's nice actually yeah that's a really
really pretty uh line and if you try to
step out of the way well I've got I've
got another idea for you how you like
that one a nice absolute pin so I think
Sabine is going to win and in the game
of Talia well uh it looked to me like
Talia had this uh completely wrapped up
so just a little bit mystified after the
move A3 I just didn't see what tatsaf
was going to do against Rook C2 the one
you mentioned before yesterday it was
really nice
A3 and B2 I just didn't see so what she
did instead She chased the Knight the
Knight had to go away and then dropped
the pawn on C2 you can't touch that pawn
that pawn uh will get you mated on the
first rank but uh after Rook C Rook F2
right is on the board yes Rook F2 so now
we need to move and I think it has to be
to chase this Knight again
um it just Rook C2 was so so in my mind
uh cut and dry I
oh I see it now I think I think this is
right if I do get you to move the night
maybe I can drop I can drop a rook on D1
right Rook on D1 and so if you played
that before yes well then in that case
maybe I should do it with the other Rook
so that's uh you're right just to
sidestep the night before for a moment
if you move the Knight
um
Knight F3 again that this is beautiful
well yeah but was I wrong uh I'm kind of
I think she just didn't want to allow
Knight takes B3 maybe after C2 Rook C2
Knight takes B3 right right Knight takes
B3 I mean okay it's still completely
winning Knight takes B3 King to A2 and
then probably I will pick up on E3 as
well
okay so maybe this is what she didn't
want to see on the board so she felt
that something like this she thought
there's something more was not good
enough not good enough no right right
it's very good of course it's completely
winning
yeah I understand okay uh well let's see
what happened in the game in the game
excuse me no Rook C2 in the game it was
Rook C8 E2 Rook of two oops that's not
right she played Rook C2 now okay
okay there must be some sort of a point
right
maybe now rookie Street or Rook c three
now yes what but I'm not sure if it
works because I see some Rook D2 exactly
yeah yeah but I just wanted to check it
out like with the accessories okay okay
so you can come to this trap if you
don't check group this way oh my
goodness but who's trying to who's out
boxing who here this is yeah still not
lost I take on D2 you take my Rook I
take on D3 okay well but that's not the
win that's not the stone cold that might
be lost
is it just a moment Talia was completely
winning two minutes ago why would so
let's see two again come back with the
Rook okay that that's the same idea
right okay now we're threatening mate
Rook takes A3 and mate so we've spent a
few moves and there's no more Knight
takes B3 at least
so you get the same position but there's
no more Knight takes B3 so wow yes wow
nicely played I have to say nicely
played yeah
nicely played man am I confused
wow
um Rook to C2
while Tata from her side she really just
doesn't have any choice yes she has to
take this phone and then yeah comes back
in order to threaten the similar mates
checkmates
that we had and moving the night does
not help
because I've got B2 and check and B1 yep
on board we're expecting to see root 288
very swiftly
wow but it's not let's say if you didn't
see this move uh from before it's
sometimes it's difficult even to think
about it this idea to move your Rook
back right so you played Rook on a a to
ca to drive the Knight away the Knight
was sitting on C1 to drive the night
away from the B3 Pawn it's on the board
okay nice nicely done by Talia but wow
uh what a sequence of moves there I
wouldn't have uh but I think it's really
great
how easy it is
let's say Knight C5 and the game still
goes on so what do we do now do we go
for a but maybe I can start with rookie
eight now
Rook E8 that's a nasty move yes
so that your threat oh never mind
well enough is enough and she just uh
resigned here wow it's a very very
unfortunate result for without deaf who
lost so many games already right we've
seen we we've seen players go on these
win Street plus two plus three uh win
streaks uh Ray honor plus but tatv just
helped me out is she on a minus two
minus three she's she's three in a row
yes three in a row yes okay yes she's on
minus one she started off very well at
the beginning of the tournament yeah but
unfortunately for her three in a row
that's devastating yes and let's take a
look at what's happening in Beckham
because I think we're going to see most
likely a resignation between Sabina and
Belgium we have room to C1 on the board
right now and Rook to F7 I really like
this move preparing what we were
discussing that moved Bishop to fa that
just kills the whole position so she
didn't even play Bishop of Fate right
she was unable to play uh Bishop to f8
because it doesn't come with check root
takes G7 doesn't come we checked so
there's no checkmating
pattern in the position yes
Rook C1
but as they say in in a bad position
there's no good moves and Rook C1 is not
saving anybody in this one
that's why to play but it's the best way
to try to
um I would assume Rook 2 F6 is
definitely works
but maybe you have to be careful about
Knight E8
um
you're still probably winning even after
this bishop D4 wow look at this one I I
think I am which is really very
fortunate for me Rook takes C7 and Rook
F7
yes but okay let's check it a little bit
this is actually quite funny and then
just seven first you think just seven
yes
[Laughter]
she played D6 which is actually uh a
hundred times better much better yeah
just but out of curiosity just we
checked this line to understand what was
happening well the very nice idea of
course is just to keep the knight in a
situation where it's in a permanent pin
there's no
um the Knight can't move it's made
instantly and it's just kind of like
asking a question what are you going to
do for a move
uh because at a certain moment D7 is
actually going to
arrive maybe just also Bishop T4 any
trades will be encouraged that will get
it upon to the seventh rank of Bishop F6
uh Sabina has not
had a good tournament uh former U.S
Champion has actually been struggling
but today she looks like she found her
best form oh bad news for uh begum
that's a brilliant victory for Sabina
and she needed this one yes because she
has been struggling in this one one and
a half out of seven is not up to par to
her standards no she's a former Champion
she knows our winning this tournament
tastes like so she's definitely looking
every single year when she participates
to replicate that same feeling and in
this event this one was a difficult one
I remembered this question was asked
because Peter Fiddler how he keeps
winning this Russian championships
like the answer was that he went all
this way he once won it he knew how to
do it yes so he keeps reading yes
definitely when you win one it's like
okay I want to go for the next and begum
again she was brilliant
in the Olympiad in India leading the
women's team and she's sitting here
suffering uh this position by the way we
talk about the satorial Splendor of
LaVon aronian in his outfits uh I think
I'm permitted to say I'm not quite sure
these days but I really like sabina's uh
glass as well very very colorful I mean
exactly look at that I don't even know
what's going on there is that
butterflies flowers
whatever it is I love the color
coordination looks great as should she
win by the way that would mean we have
only two draws out of the seven games in
the women's championships five to
society we came in saying 50 percent
victories well guys uh we're gonna keep
that percentage pretty high
and Christian you are with guests we are
with atalia Cervantes Talia first of all
uh congratulations welcome to the show a
pre-tame event so far for you one loss
all the other uh ended in a draw but
finally you're back to 50 how do you
feel right now
um well first of all it's great to be
here finally
um uh I think it's good I think I'm in
good track now that I had my first win
it took maybe too long
but overall I feel like my games have
just been like weirdly solid I don't
know
um and obviously my game against Serena
that was like total total mess I didn't
understand my positions but I'm glad
that at least I I have a win now so
you're feeling good about your shape at
this point in tournament yeah and it's
always nice to win with black so a lot
to look forward to let's look at the the
game what were the critical moments in
your opinion right so
um I had the opening prep but I feel
like maybe she had it prepped better the
line that we played specifically is not
the one that I thought she was going to
play this is a very authoritical one
right right uh I mean I based on her
games I thought she was going to play
something slightly different but yes
this is quite theoretical and you have
until night B6 Queen 05 Bishop H6
um takes takes uh Queen D2 rogate shade
F4 and here here I was
um lost and Mary was visible due to the
note that I played
um and I don't think it was the right
idea either because I definitely didn't
like the position that I got in the
middle game it felt like later things
were easing a little bit but
um E4 was a little bit too ambitious it
was too ambitious yeah and honestly
um I thought that after the
complications like after E4 she play can
be won and then takes obviously I think
if she takes on the on D6 directly like
after 97 yes then my position is fine
like I'm doing pretty good my knight
goes to E6 and everything everything
looks good
um but obviously she can play for for
more than that and not trade Queens
right so after that I wasn't so sure but
yeah I definitely misplayed it F5 was a
really good move by here I really
totally missed it
um
because if I take choices 934 and Knight
at five yes and that is very very
dangerous night uh he's probably gonna
check with you yeah no I I can't afford
to allow that not looking good for sure
um but you put you found this move King
to f8 which was a very crafty move well
my idea is just to get away as fast as I
can
um and it also opens the possibility for
98 and
um yeah just worst case scenario try and
trade Queen straight
and get out of the way so for example if
takes on G6 in that position I was
thinking to go 98 and that wasn't the
the C1 because I think if I go with the
other one there might be some
um yeah yeah C5 and now if you take take
there's another night hanger
um so the other Knight 28 Rook to B6 is
forced you trade trade then take on G6
right right how did you assess this m
game
um I didn't love it because my
appointment B7 is still a big problem
and my pieces were very discordinated uh
but okay
there's a lot of fun in the position for
sure
um so she played C5 yeah I definitely
didn't like my position but I was trying
to get back somehow B5 I felt like it
was necessary otherwise the bishop and
C4 is just super strong I don't love it
because in 19496 ideas but
um I mean it just I think it just had to
happen yeah and I think once we got into
more of time trouble
um uh when did you feel like you're
finally getting your own chances in this
game yeah I felt like I had something
but
um so instead of queen queen E4 I was
thinking Queen E5 but we were also
getting a little bit low on time and I
didn't know how to assess this move six
minutes for her 13 minutes for you at
this point right so technically I could
put pressure on her I I guess I just
missed
um what my continuations are because I
thought yes something like night two uh
D4 maybe Knight C3 yeah Knight C3 and
then that'd be an idea yes yeah it
sounds like takes and then Knight B3 and
I saw something like this where I didn't
know how to what to think of it right
it's not easy to assess this position
it's like typical Sicilian you just
don't know what's going on
um but yeah so after the trade obviously
I felt like I was heading into this and
again not in good shape because the
opponent C6 is very well defended but I
guess just things happened
um the more the game went on here I was
like okay now you're feeling it yeah
yeah once the night lands on e4 now now
I'm okay and I felt like I should be
winning somehow it is um and even if I
couldn't see right away the the correct
continuation
um is like all of her pieces are tied
down yeah right because for example
first I wanted to play
um uh yeah after Knight C1 B3 A3 I
wanted to play Rook C2 but then there's
Rook B4 so uh and yeah I guess it's
still completely winning but I don't
want to allow anything
either
um so yeah because some pieces are so
tied down it just has to be winning in
many ways it's not that clear right
right they they can
then
um Talia still after that it felt like
you converted quite nicely
congratulations an important victory for
you we're looking forward to see you in
the next few rounds thank you so much
well Dan Talia nice to see you in the
studio Italia like to see you more often
as a guest exactly welcome back welcome
back in in our remaining game against
Sabina feizer putting the finishing
touches on this one she's just played
the move uh D6 to D7 I couldn't decide
whether or not I would rather her put
the Rook there first and then play D7 in
order uh to keep the Knight but then I
just suddenly realized you know what in
case you move your knight I'm just gonna
Queen yes that's true but I mean they
were and so what's the problem what
about Rook d8 this is what I was
wondering
like I really don't know if rookie then
Rook takes D7 yeah I think I just play
Bishop
seven though take on D7 and I think you
get perhaps what I call the those
Immortal pins but this is not that easy
right CSS okay you take ah no but you
can take on G7 yes sir oh sorry
oh well then I have to take on F7
exactly and then Rook to G8 okay how is
this yeah this was what I was thinking
this is the immortal pin right right
but so
oh and then you get the king to oh this
is
this is naughty so this is some kind of
now G3 right no no G3 oh this is nice
guys guys check this out
wow it even just came up uh in the
database you ready for my next move wow
don't go to H6 no please
I don't want to allow stale mates any
any so
um whatever what let me just refresh my
board for a quick moment but it just
looks like uh yes she's displayed Bishop
E7 so it's a soul this uh wow nice
yes
this one is pretty much over
wow such a simply calculated until then
actually I was thinking I was thinking
uh what goes through her mind right now
why she took so long why it took her so
long to find the move but probably she
just tried to figure it out until the
end by the way did I blunder something
like how did we get in that position
I think one to seven so what if the
other goes well I mean I'm threatening
to go Bishop takes d8 yes exactly yes
and you cannot move your Rook you have
to take it like this but then how did we
allow The Rook to get to G8 yes
you can just take on the a yeah but then
I could take the Rook on d8 ah yes come
on come on you guys are my roof you're
here to protect me
um these oversights
but I really like this idea oh yeah
that's a good example actually how you
win this type of food right positions
with pins yeah these um what these
Eternal pins yes I must say when it at
first befell me I felt so physically
helpless my opponent had a rook on the
eighth rank I had a bishop on f8 and the
King on G8 and he had a bishop on F6 and
it absolutely couldn't move it just felt
like ah it was like horrible horrifying
uh feeling of helplessness and that's
what uh begum is feeling as well after
we see this move Bishop E7 I think
sometimes you just have to throw in the
towel you have to do it at some point
yeah yeah it's just it simply is over at
this point
there's no coming back from this
okay yeah this looks uh looks Dreadful
and
forbegam as she came in at today's round
how was she faring in terms of the
leaderboard she was I think she had
somebody she had some promising hopes
right third position she died for the
first place coming into today's round
she has four points
better loss today will
that's really really knock her way down
no that would mean she will be on 50
percent
four out of uh eight
so yes I mean she's way behind uh the
leading pack right now
um
right
okay yeah it's it's a very difficult
position was publishable resigned soon
or we'll try maybe Rook the seven and
that's it well what other tricks could
she possibly have you cannot even move
your Rook ready but that's the problem
yeah you go King G8 I just simply take
on G7 yeah exactly exactly that's uh
there's no tricks in the position
I mean there are no no joy in Mudville
as we would say no and there are no our
Outsiders also in this event like even
those who are on the bottom of the table
can strike back any moment as you can
see what Wesley said too the problem
with the U.S Championship is any given
and any given round uh somebody can
create an upset in these Junior players
boy they do swing for the fences and
you're seeing it also in the women's
event so Sabina Pfizer uh former
Champion uh was struggling for the most
of the tournament so far and said I I'm
I'm going to be your victim not today
just not today
67 and we're expecting Bishop takes F6
and again just pinning that night yeah
and it's over a group of seven Rook of
seven and there is no way to defend this
Knight not only that but also your king
is in real danger of just getting
checkmated exactly yeah your king is not
safe and no stalemates either thanks to
the G6 and H5 pawns Bishop takes F6 on
the board excuse me
yeah you would dream of some Brook age
one check but there's nothing happening
no after Rook hd7 yeah this is over guys
an important victory for Sabina for sure
relaunch not necessarily her campaign to
win the championship I'm pretty sure
she's still very far away from that but
still she's dreaming of a good placement
exactly it should just kind of
recovering her competitive Zeal for the
tournament as Sophia Morris was saying
that you know it's one thing when you're
preparing and you're looking forward
because you've got something you know
you're you're you're aspiring to get on
the podium and it's another thing when
the results are just not coming your way
as well you're preparing hard but
there's no results ah it's depressing
yes Wesley I think also gave up a little
bit he's a chances to be the first
um yeah this event you know like he kind
of admits the fact that I'm three points
behind Fabrics
exactly yeah five five rounds left three
points behind even though we saw
different examples remember how far we
woke up the the last five rounds in the
official random and suddenly started to
beat everyone I think he made four and a
half out of five something like this and
uh died for the first place he woke up
uh in last year's U.S Championship as
well because he was having a dreadful
event on and yeah he won I believe uh
three or four in a row to actually catch
up with the leaders and force the
playoff he lost that playoff but still
he never gave up and this is the key you
can never give up in this tournament
because also as Wesley pointed out the
prize fund has increased so there's
definitely a lot of things to be playing
for yes so even if you are not the
winner of the championship still I mean
if you remember
yeah for second place I mean it's not
shameful to be second right in this
event at all
you you have a dream to be so good right
as well exactly I mean it's really
really decent price funding
yeah
and uh beg him is not sure what she's
she's trying her last chance I guess
with Rook D6 maybe you don't see that
I'm attacking the bishop and you take
with the Rook on G7
um Sabina seems to be Singh the bishop
on F6 is under attack so she's probably
going to take on G7 with the bishop and
then move her look on and then just move
and I was thinking uh Bishop takes G7
check King to G8 I was going to move my
Bishop fancy just just anchor everything
and protect it's it's the vultures yes
the vouchers are correct coming in
coming in hot correct nice
Bishop E5 is like very fancy move
the problem is even if you exchange the
Rooks and the F Pawn it's still the
right promotion Square it's exactly the
right color so not even those type of
end games will ever save you in this
position exactly
just pay attention Sabina still checks
every possible option in this position
because even she knows of course she's
winning this game she checks a couple of
times to make sure that they're sure to
be sure to be sure absolutely yes I mean
it's it's really normal yeah and
especially if you're having a bad
tournament then you're doubting yourself
so you double guess and again it's not
bad to a little bit of nervousness uh
keeps you on guard okay yeah sir you
want to be oh
look I mean the moment she played my
move look what happened guys all right
at this moment wow and once again what a
decisive round I mean goodness gracious
five out of the seven games and in the
in the men's section we had our diet of
two out of seven but there you have our
current standings with the with round
eight in the history books well as if
she was tied uh be uh for a fifth
position before at this round and once
again the game is still tied for fifth
position yes
so Megan Lee is on the first place with
six points only half a point behind
Arena crash who made the draw today Jen
and Jennifer you as well with five and a
half points and then we have Ellis Lee
on clear Force position happy birthday
Alice Lee 13 years old very compact
field I have to say nobody's running
with the event yes
it's a Chase and you get wanded on the
way out as part of our fair play
and in the open and we've all I think
we've already discovered discussed uh
but in the open we have Fabi and Ray
playing like 2900s exactly yes sir my
performance so well and followed by oil
linear Domingos and Jeff is strong also
direswears and sam7 as well as a
Wonderland all of them had poor and half
points very very nicely
and we're just going to wait for Sabina
to come over and share with us her
Pleasant Victor Victory it's always nice
to have in studio of course
predictions
did well yes as well as my rules we have
to admit it yeah but I our our selection
is open
well I mean if I had gotten Ray right I
would have been kind of pleased with
that but Lavon really I just it
sometimes you just don't have a good
event and it's not just the positions is
like the openings it's as prep something
is it's very similar to what's happening
with Wesley in uh that competition for
example exactly through moderator
favorites are just simply struggling but
my boy Jeffrey he won today
I believed on him seven draws very very
stable place and then he scores
plenty of games
not on the Christmas list
[Laughter]
sorry look look what can I do what can I
do the people have spoken uh but yeah
Sabina uh when you look at the
tournament feel for the ladies you see a
lot of a lot of Champions in that field
honest atomski great Champion not doing
particularly well at this moment but you
never count these players out Naji oh
what a painful loss that was today yes
because I'm telling you when she played
that move Bishop takes B7 she probably
thought it's gonna it was close super
close to making it easy 97 comes like
and I mean you don't even have a bailout
no you don't have a draw don't don't
even have a drawer it's really really
crazy exactly yes let me just pull that
game up so at least our audience can
understand
how cruel chess can be so uh more or
less since the opening well since the
opening 9 energy had sacrificed upon
always for better development
threats initiatives she gets to this
position she sees them it was Bishop F5
and she seizes the moment she says my
goodness I can just take both of these
pawns
life is wonderful Bishop takes B7 please
let me play one more move Rook takes A6
I'll trade Rooks I've got two connected
past bonds signed my score sheet you are
lost
and it's sort of like oh my gosh what a
shocking move that was she did end up
losing a piece she tried to fight on
valiantly two ponds versus Bishop didn't
work and lost the game Christian over to
you
Sabina a difficult tournament for you up
to this point but finally you get that
breakout Victory how do you feel it
right now thank you thanks for having me
here I feel good it's great to win one
game you know it's yesterday's been a
tough day for for me
um realizing what happened to elshon and
I just couldn't play and then I saw so
much I felt like it was hatred coming
towards him and I'm quite emotional as a
person so I just did something about it
I did I did on Instagram yeah I I felt
like he it can happen to anyone to just
blunder out of the opening and I just
felt really bad because you know it
happened to him and of course you know
we're so close and
um I was just you know very mad at
everyone and of course mad at myself
because I felt that although I haven't
really scored many points I feel that
overall my play was pretty decent I mean
maybe I would have some bad
positions out of the opening let's say
but I was able to come back in a lot of
the games but the results of course of
course don't show and typically I like
to
to inspire other people that's something
that I've always wanted and then
um showing people that you should never
give up it doesn't matter how bad your
tournament is going you should just keep
fighting I think that's something that I
want everyone to to kind of see and
believe in themselves and just as a
tough game but
um
you should never give up you should
always fight so and I think he also
mentioned this on one of your posts on
social media and you mentioned your
sponsor as well for this tournament
would you like to give a shout out to
your sponsor thanks for that yeah so um
I think it's really nice when you have
students that care about you not just
they don't just take lessons with you
because
you know they they like you or they
think you can help them but they also
are inspired by you and
um
Steve is actually one of elshon students
and he was very nice to
um to support us during this tournament
so I'm just very thankful for him I've
been wearing all the gear I actually
have it underneath this shirt yes we've
seen it take us through today's game
because it was indeed a very tense
battle it was like yeah so
it was a last minute decision actually I
did
I wasn't sure what um
she would play I know she's your
students I know you sometimes play the
groomfield and I was like okay maybe
she'll play this but in the tournament
she didn't really play it and then
literally last minute I remember that I
played some H4 in a game three four
years ago was this before the round and
before before of course before the round
yeah yeah I I looked a little bit and I
was like okay what do I do and I
actually had no idea what I would go for
and then I was like okay let's just go
H4 and see what happens
H5 I don't think is the best I don't
think it's the very good choice
what is this movie but of course the
position whatever you play even H5 is
not like losing yeah of course nature I
mean the idea is to kind of try to drag
the Knight away taking G6 and but white
doesn't really have any attack so I I I
was happy when she played H5 and you
know I have the tendency sometimes when
I don't have a good tournament to just
start throwing my pieces out and I told
myself I will not I will not do that so
I try to play as positional as possible
just develop my pieces I think
um yeah I missed this idea with A4 of
hers I thought I would have Queen B3 and
I would be fine and then she played day
four and yeah
oh B4 I could have played or B3 yeah B3
yeah also makes a lot of sense uh yeah
so here
I was trying to find a way to improve
the position because I think white is a
little bit better with the center and
black is struggling to play C5 for E5
and that's usually what you want to do
so yeah I don't know if I played the
best but I like Knight D5 and then I
thought she had to take and here you're
still maintaining yeah the balance yeah
and then here I took with the queen you
know I thought sometime I thought
I should take with the pawn that's
normal and then go to K1 and trade
pieces are Equity one or something
that's what I thought but then I was
like no no Queen B3 looks nice because
she cannot take any four because G6 is
hanging and
yeah good position and
she played this move uh King to H7
getting yes of this diagonal of course
yeah Knight C3 I think it was good she
played all the moves that I thought she
would play and then even like I thought
Queen 8 and queen A7 and here I couldn't
come up with a plan because she does
want some Knight A4
I thought
and then try to trade them three as well
yeah okay three first Knight A4 try to
trade the knight uh
yes so if I go back to F3 basically I
let the C4 square right yeah
I was like okay what have I done I need
to do something on the other side so
that's why I went F4 and oh it was bad
okay great apparently this is 33 was
getting some problems F6 I think she
just didn't realize that she weakened Z6
the E6 Square so once I went back I
think Knight C4 has to be played
Knight to C4 or Rook 283 still to be the
best Queen E6 Queen to E6
um I think F5 but this is already yeah
it's very messy yeah very computer-ish
right and she played this move Knight
way4
yeah trade and 95 I thought was a
mistake because of course I have Rook C5
and suddenly I have F5 which is gorgeous
perhaps this is what she missed yeah I
think so I think she probably missed
that
uh what were you what was the move I
thought she would she would take uh in
A2 and then I still wanted to take yeah
and I thought you had to come somehow
with the queen to trade with Queen V8
but so maybe Queen 25 attack and then
and still Roxy Five right something like
this to see five the same thing yeah
try to do things of this nature
but still the position remained
complicated and she made this big
mistake with Knight to B5 root to C5
yeah and then she went back she probably
realized that it's not looking very good
oh F5 was why did she not take on A2 at
this point uh F5 F5 yeah I thought it's
yeah or King side guess shattered yeah
very nice I was yeah I was quite
confident with my rook in C5 and I knew
ideas with B6 would not work because she
dropped C6
and um
yeah going into this I panicked here at
some point I guess I haven't played the
best we were both getting really low on
time and she had yeah she had some ideas
some very aggressive ideas I hope I
didn't miss a mate or something at this
point things got really messy right and
you actually found this key move King to
F3 to defend the position you know I've
lost uh against Jennifer you I had a
pretty I thought I saved it after the
time travel and then there was some kind
of idea with two Rooks mating me and I
was like okay I will not get mated
that's the point so you're getting
flashbacks from I I was yeah the tough
thing I think it's very hard to do when
you're playing a tournament because
especially as long as this one because
you always have these memories in your
head what are you gonna do and yeah so
but she played this move night which
yeah I thought after that it just should
be totally lost managed to paint the
night and convert it nicely yeah Sabina
congratulations big victory for you uh
what are you going to do to tonight to
celebrate I'm just going to call by the
two people actually have been three
people supporting me today and I'm just
gonna call them
immediately be thankful uh for for
believing in me and um then of course
just uh you know it's just a game I have
to to keep playing tomorrow plenty of
rounds to go five rounds yeah
Sabina congratulations we'll see you
tomorrow thanks
our congratulations as well it is it is
so believe in yourself no matter what
happens and you know that Victory uh
really
reinforces the idea I I I'm okay I can
play chess it's uh really really
important but uh Christian uh bring our
broadcast to a close with final thoughts
of another very eventful round eight I
mean we are entering the last uh five
rounds and the tournaments are both
hitting up and we thought that Fabiano
might be running away with the event and
it was looking good for him today with
the black pieces he could have
potentially scored an important Victory
but Ray is definitely well lurking in
the back only half a point behind
Fabiano so that finish is going to be
explosive and in the ladies section
Megan Lee and Irina Crush also early
sleep what an important victory for the
young lady we have a lot of Chess left
in this tournament and we will be here
to call all the action tomorrow with
round nine thank you indeed Christian
right you are all results seem possible
Anastasia another great day calling the
action with you thank you very much for
being with us thank you all for sharing
your day and joining and especially for
your uh queries to our panel we enjoy
them as always
have a good night good night see you
tomorrow
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited